Dude, Hutch is getting Hutch is getting filled. Hutch is airtight
right now. That's a disgusting visual. I know I don't want to
put that in your mind, but Jesus Christ. Why did Soy Pillow have
to come in and point out the hypocrisy, too? How is this from
the situation is any less valid? It just means it's easier for
you, which is true, but it doesn't invalidate your opinion. So,
it's literally irrelevant. >> I I It's mostly irrelevant,
but but the question is like the ultimate question. Well, it's
I I mostly irrelevant, but I >> Wait, what is the relevance
I Wait, wait, oh, sorry. What is THE RELEVANCE
>> THE HUTCH PISCO STUFF, OKAY? Probably the Hutch Pisco
stuff. It is pretty
I don't know if you guys know this, but
Hutch and Pisco I think got into a little bit of an argument
today on Livin' Learn. We're going to cover that, but we're also
going to cover a little bit of the background where Pisco kind
of critiques Hutch's tweets from last
All right? Cuz I I need a little I need a little preview.
Okay? Little preview.
Let me Let me see if we can uh Let me put the title in, and then
we're going to go over to that, okay?
Aren't they boys? Well, you might think they're boys, but we
don't know we don't know for sure. Okay, this all goes into the
shutdown stuff. I'm not going to do a whole bunch on the shutdown.
Essentially, the Dems crossed over, decided to work with Republicans
to pass a continuing resolution to refund the government, get
the government going again, and Dems probably think Here's the
Here's my my not totally informed opinion, okay? For me, I really
really
that politically the Dems were winning this like 10x. Like 10
to 1 the Dems were winning on this. I think overall everybody's
reputation is going down, but you are burying Trump right now.
You are absolutely burying him. And so, stopping this makes no
sense to me.
And for some reason they crossed the line. Like it makes sense
in a oh, we care about the country way, but politically no sense,
okay?
Politically makes no sense. That's my read on it. I'm not as
informed, probably even as Hutch is, right? I'm probably not
even as informed on this Hutch is, but
I don't see any other way to see it, and I see a lot of smart
people echoing that
So, Hutch Hutch has been going off on Twitter in a couple different
places about it how it's like really defensible that the Dems
are doing this, and Here's Here's his tweet from today. We'll
get into Pisco reviewing the tweets last night, and then we'll
go over to Livin' Learn where they actually start arguing about
this, okay?
Just want to know, did you talk about the conservative MPs that
left?
Uh are Wait, are you What are you talking about, Frank Cino?
The conservative MPs that left. Is that Canadian politics? If
it's If you're just talking about Canadian politics, obviously
not.
Probably un- It's unlikely that I talk about Canadian politics
on here. All right. Okay, to steel man, the three most common
arguments I've seen for prolonged shutdown. Force the country
to face the consequences of Trump. Maybe that devastates GOP
politically. GOP maybe scraps filibuster benefits
scraps filibuster benefits Dems more in the long run. GOP maybe
folds, extends tax credits. Here These are what I think are reasonable
counters. There's a risk There's a risk of so much chaos and
pain that eventually the medium voter is equally to both parties.
There is There was zero indication that Thune was open to scrapping
the
Okay? There is zero indication of this,
Okay? I'm definitely I I definitely agree that this shutdown
fight could have been stretched a bit longer. What I'm definitely
not sympathetic to is the idea that it could have gone on indefinitely.
It's so difficult to justify 41 million SNAP recipients being
cut off for months. The courts compelled Trump to use emergency
funds to send out SNAP payments, but those will dry up completely
in a couple of weeks. Oh, then this is super It's even more than
he's letting on. No!
Wait, they They were going to have to continue SNAP payments?
And you're folding already? I understand how important SNAP payments
are. I really do. I really do get it. But that's part of what
makes it important to stand on.
The courts compelled Trump to use the emergency funds for this.
Um They'll be dried up a couple weeks, and at that point we're
talking about a level of pain that defeats the entire purpose
of what Dems are fighting for in the first
I understand what he's saying that like you're you're standing
on Medicare cuts. You got to stand on something, bro. You got
to stand on something.
These are, for example, 2K per month households of single parents
and two kids. The benefits these families qualify for quite literally
what allows them to survive. It's easy for me to say hold the
line for however long it takes when I'm not the one facing eviction
or
But hold on. This works both ways. Huh? Uh We're asking for something
so small that it feels crazy for us to uphold to to keep benefits
away from these people. Okay, so why don't the Republicans concede
on this?
If it's so tiny, doesn't this work both
Doesn't this easily work both ways? And then ultimately Trump
is the one who like tried to defend direct SNAP SNAP benefits
away from those people who like had to be fought on that? Who
didn't want to use emergency funds to pay out SNAP benefits?
I don't know. Anyway, the These are Hutch's tweets from this
morning, so they're not going to be included in the next segment
we do, which is going to be on Pisco's reading of his tweets.
Give me a second.
Give me a second. Give me a second. Looking for this clip. Wait,
where is it? Wait, where is it? I've lost it. I've lost it. Give
me a second. I'll find it. Believe Rile sent me a DM with these.
Rile, why can't I find this in my
Oh, I know. That's why. Hold on. I know
Here's the timestamp where Pisco's reviewing Hutch's tweets.
Let's check it out. We can go straight from here into Livin'
Learn, okay?
It's just it's off. Um we we need to speak out against this,
man. We need to speak out against this, and I'm I'm going to
be Oh, wait. Quick, Hutch. Let's take a look at Hutch's Twitter.
I promised we'd do that, right? One sec.
>> We'll do a Hutch Twitter review. And I am fired up.
>> Twitter review. Review.
Hutch Twitter review. Everybody knows Listen, everybody knows
that Hutch's content cuz he's like kind of making a total ass
of himself all the time. >> I want to make sure he's saying
the right things. Good times.
Once again, after chatters and uh instead of your friends tweets,
the argument to show this is bad. What do you want, Democrat?
I don't know what you mean by that.
All right, Hutch's first is Oh, wow.
Turns out
people can be in every chat. It's not just my chat. Oh my god,
people write totally like non-English sentences all the time.
Ah! It's beautiful seeing another other influencer get one of
those. All right, decent reaction.
Responding to Ryan Malley.
I don't think so. Didn't get enough for your leverage. The left
is furious. This is a like um something I don't like, and I love
how Hutch is my boy. Where it's always like
Every time Hutch is my boy. Hutch is my boy. Every time he says
it, I'm going to play the sound effect.
Referring to third parties.
Like I don't think that I'm sorry. I'm I'm I'm doing a impression
cuz it helps me like think about what he would say.
I don't think that that is strategic for Manchin to do that.
Or like I don't Why would Schumer do that? As though like rather
than speak about the norms as he sees them, sometimes I I find
it frustrating when people do that where like we'll externalize
it to
uh speaking about groups and their incentive structures. Like
it doesn't really make sense for Israel to do that, right? It
doesn't make sense for Israel to come to negotiation on this
or that. Or it doesn't make sense for to give this up, right?
Like we're asking about norms, right? You know what I'm talking
about? He's my boy. Um But then he does say this hurts people.
To be honest, it's probably benefits Hold on. Why is he talking
so fast? norms, right? You know what I'm talking about? He's
my boy. Um
But then he does say this hurts people. To be honest, it's probably
benefits Dems. Again, in terms of like external parties and their
and but he Although he does but I'd rather get tax credit extensions.
Um maybe there he's he's talking about like his personal incentives
are not aligned necessarily with the positioning on um I actually
don't know what he means with this the tax credit extension.
I'd rather get tax credit extensions.
Well, he's basically suggesting that if Dems were purely
pragmatically thinking, they would let this hurt Americans. Yes.
Yes.
And that he's not interested just in political outcomes. So,
I guess that's a decent response. Uh to be I agree that Schumer
caving is really bad. Good. We love this, Hutch. But the
Not good. Not good for Pisco's mental,
I agree that Schumer caving is really
Insane premium spikes are just going to disproportionately impact
Trump voters. It's going to be painful for him. He can dance
all he wants, but who does he think that voters will be blamed
for
W- That's what I don't mean Like you say you agree it's really
bad, but this will hurt voters.
I don't understand the but, right? Like you're you're suggesting
that this is bad for net bad for Democrats, but that it maybe
it's not.
To be clear, millions losing cover It's almost like he's not
taking a position. He's trying to ride the fence, okay? Hutch
is picking splinters out of his ass from
from humping that fence to death, okay? He will not leave that
fence post. That's where he is. That's where he set up. That's
where he wants to be. Coverage of tens of millions are enormous.
Premium spikes is objectively awful. I I I guess he's just saying
he's he thinks that in the net it might be more of a wash.
But again, I I I just think that then like why would you agree
that it's bad, right? Like if if you're not sure whether or not
this is going to be Also, it's like I can clearly define the
bads from Schumer caving politically, right? I can clearly define
the bads. He's saying hypothetically there's some future where
it's not as bad. You understand that means definitely still just
it's a horrible decision to cave, right? If you can like barely
quantify some hypothetical situation in the future where maybe
it gets almost as bad for Republicans,
that's just bad. Good
for the Democrats long term or achieve the policy aims.
Why would you agree it's really bad? It just feels like this
is a little empty if if you're not as sure about the political
ramifications
and policy ramifications, you know? I feel like uncertainty on
that front mitigates the mitigates the potential for um
for thing it's going to be really bad or at least coming to this
determination. Does that make sense what I'm saying?
Again, I love Hutch. We'll talk about it tomorrow, I'm sure.
He's saying some of the right things. >> That's That's
the same thing. Hutch is my boy or whatever. >> million
people seeing dramatic increases to their premiums and losing
coverage. I have no idea why anyone would think that doesn't
hurt Trump with his own voters. I think it will, but like
that was The thing is that's true regardless of if you have a
deal or no deal, right? Like that dynamic of blaming Republicans
for that is consistent. And so it can't be a basis to distinguish
whether you should have had the deal or not because that just
is premised on them being unamenable to actually passing it,
which they still are, right? >> Especially go by like the
very tepid statements of optimism from the Democrats defectors.
Do you understand what I'm saying then? Like
This thing is consistent, right? The blame for the
potential is consistent with a deal without a deal. And so it
can't be a basis to distinguish the action here,
And then obviously that Trump isn't running for election or at
least you know whatever. Dems can do all the resistance they
want. I'm inclined to think they should hold the line on this
one. Again, that seems like kind of to mitigate the it's really
bad to to cave if you are inclined. It seems like you're kind
of more moderate about it. Um but Trump Republicans are 1,000%
responsible for tax credits expiring. I I mean I agree with that.
That's true
of the shutdown, too.
situation Healthcare bite If Trump refuses to build an inch on
the healthcare shutdown fight and this is precisely where we
are at 5 weeks, how do you propose them avert the looming crisis?
They have the power to prevent this according to you, so how?
So again, then if you're unsure about the position of the Democrats,
why do you think it's bad? But then retweeting Governor Newsom
is good and Pritzker's good. I think 99% of Democrats believe
that Biden choosing to step down and pass the baton to a fresher
face would have been the right thing to do. Schumer's about the
time.
I generally think he's been an effective Senate leader through
the years. That's not the >> Yeah, that's fine. That's
fine. >> why actually is this strength for Trump? Okay.
So we're going to rate this um seven out of 10 response
bec- Okay. That's I'm going to say it That was just him saying
I love Hutch again, okay? That seven out of 10, that's actually
a really hidden I love
I love Hutch. Hutch is my boy. Because of the comments on Schumer,
the retweeting of the base people um but I'm not convinced that
as though he's like sort of positioning it the contrast between
Schumer's doing really bad, but This is one of those things where
it's like Hutch is clearly going to be biased for the establishment
Democrats times like like what really biased for them. And so
what he's doing is he's going, I totally disagree with this decision,
but there's like some way where it might not be that bad a decision.
Right? It's like fence-sitting. It's It's running defense. It's
It's like not a good It's like It's like that should be That
can be something you talk about.
I feel like you got to be very clear about your your anger over
the the failure first and then you can talk about how like, there
are some silver linings here after. I don't know. It feels like
he's he's putting them together. It's not like totally re- But
I don't know. Listen, if Hutch isn't standing on that or if he's
he if he's like backing off of that
I don't know. Why Why am I hearing that there was a big fight
after this? Oh, wait wait wait wait wait wait. Before we go to
that real quick. Hutch reacting to the Hasan clip. Hold
Hasan, if you guys missed it, Hasan decided to fire some shots
back at Hutch today, okay? I haven't played it for you yet, but
there's a clip of Hasan firing some shots and that's what we're
about to watch.
Oh my god, did we get a reaction? We won, guys. Triggered him,
bro.
ality. Uh
so gay.
Except Hutch is calling it a masterful gamble. When has Hutch
ever been right in his entire political career? Please Please
never [laughter] bring that bald loser's name in this chat ever
again. We're actually having an Dude, I don't know. How
I'll be honest. I'll be honest, okay?
I just have to Somebody send me I don't know. Somebody send me
a clip of Hasan being just a total narcissist again. I need a
I need to not love this guy cuz that's just
>> Please never bring that bald loser's name in this chat
ever again. We're actually having an adult conversation about
the goddamn Democratic Party and its failures. I don't need to
hear from someone who doesn't know anything and his only investment
in this is to basically either say Hasan [__] Hasan
[__] over and over again. Oh my god,
Did I get under Did I get under his skin? I don't know if he's
aware of this, but it's kind of [__] up that he's
uh pointing to my baldness.
Oh, hair transplant uh hair transplant for an asteroid. Let's
go. As a line of attack? This is By the way, this is what I've
always said, okay? Hutch, when Hutch can snark on Hasan, Hutch
is fully in his element. Hutch is not happier He's not happy
in life, okay? He's not happy when he goes out in the world.
He's not happy when he goes to sleep at night. He's not happy
when he streams most of the time, but when he gets an opportunity
to snark on Hasan
that's where he locks the [__] in. He is psyched
to be alive. He can feel it. He feels electrified
the second the opportunity arises, okay? And here it is. Hasan
himself giving him props tell letting him know, Hutch, you annoy
me. And he's like, oh, I just never felt anything better than
this in my whole
Huh, pretty [__] up. I don't think he knows the deep
lore. Uh my parents forced me to wear a shock
I don't like talking about it, but Oh, that went in a totally
different direction. I thought he was going to talk about Wait,
is he Come on. You're not going to mention the finasteride that
Hasan's hairline was going away and he had to he had to remedy
it before he went bald, too?
And anytime I got out of line, they zapped me and it just just
a totally
lame It's just a totally lame joke. But uh I'm glad you got your
dunk, bro. Okay, because it's Call of Duty It's Bro, how How
are there There's so many people laughing in the chat? I don't
I don't get it. I don't get it.
imploded in of itself and he decided to What the [__]
How dare him?
>> I was a thriving
Call of Duty professional gamer.
That doesn't know [__] Does he know how many Warzone
wins I got? I have a plaque. Like where is it? In my closet somewhere.
I had like 500 wins or something. So cool. >> hitch his
wagon to like >> cool. Destiny.
>> Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh,
no. Now Hasan Hasan, he was joking. The bald thing doesn't really
bother Hutch, but now Hasan said the thing that actually bothers
him and now that's [__] up, okay?
That's just [__] up, bro. Hold on. I'm going to go
back to the start of the reaction here. He has place-trained
his
so remarkably well.
Like this guy should write a book
on how to place-train your audience. Dude, I might have been
wrong about how good a A-log he is. The only thing he has is
is collar gate. It's all he's got. Is collar gate. Bro, there's
so many insane Hasan things that you could bring up. It's just
You only got collar gate, bro?
This is a pathetic display. Pathetic display. What are you doing,
man?
There's like There's like a a veritable cornucopia of Hasan snark
you could go to and you just keep hitting collar gate over and
over again. Because his obedient little dogs
show up in my mentions and they just repeat the same things.
It's like It's like four or five things that you see
uh like green regularity.
You're just jealous cuz he's hot and he has a lot of money and
he drives a Porsche, you know, something like that. You're just
jealous that you didn't get invited to the DNC. Actually, I did,
but I said no.
By the DNC or by Not So Erudite?
By the DNC or by Not So Erudite? Be honest. Be honest, Hutch.
Be honest. I hear the same cope for people. It's not like it's
bad that you got invited by Erudite, but like be honest about
who invited you. Don't lie about who invited you. Be honest.
Regretfully.
I honestly, in retrospect, wish I would have gone. They say
What's the other thing that they say? They say um
Oh, you're criticizing Hasan. Do you know who else criticizes
Hasan? JD
Asmongold. Yes, you agree with JD Vance and This is weak. Asmongold.
So they do that one. There's got to be a fallacy for that, by
the way. They accuse me of hitching my wagon to Destiny, an individual
that I have not communicated with since like a year.
And in the past, I communicated When you're in a When you're
in a snarking war, Hutch's first instinct was good, although
it's just collar gate. His first instinct was good. Hasan's just
you and you go, oh, every Every lie that upsets me from these
people are these
Don't do that. Don't do that. Hit back. Hit back or just laugh
at them and move on. Do one one comment, move on. Breaking down
all the things where you're trying to defend yourself from their
criticisms, that's not a good play. I understand it. I do that
sometimes. I don't I don't think about what the intelligent thing
to say is, okay? And I'll just be like, well, that's clearly
not true.
Come on, man. with like a total of like 10 to 15 times, maybe.
I've only been in Destiny's apartment
I've only been in Destiny's apartment once, actually. I've only
I've only done a few I've only done a couple. I haven't done
a lot of pieces of content with him. I've only been in his apartment
Was Hutch there for the election stream? I can't remember. I
don't think so. I think he missed the election stream, but was
there for a podcast episode.
So, it might be twice, actually.
Why are Why are you focused on Hassan when there's a Destiny
when there's a Destiny in Gaza? Oh my god. I think the question
that happens there is it seem you're concerned about Kyles seems
a little performative when you have somebody who you have had
interactions with who you've not criticized anywhere near as
much for like probably morally worse interactions with people,
right? That's the That's the comparison there is like is this
really that big an issue or do you kind of let go of some other
things that are probably worse? That's probably the question
you get asked there. We're just We're just going to start combining
them. Really? You're going to criticize Hassan
while there's a Destiny happening in Gaza right now?
And he drives a Porsche while you don't.
Just got to combine all them. So, that's that's four of them
and then what are some of the other ones?
He's like not good at this.
I think feel like I'm missing like a
I want to finish the segment just real quick cuz this is supposed
to be a preview before we go to [laughter] the Pisco stuff, but
holy [__] Hutch, please. Hutch, please. And then
there's just like yeah, just like bald or like like literal fifth
grader insults, like
fifth grader insults. He likes to do to do those.
On the panel that he was on for
Crooked Con, he called Greg Gutfeld
Greg Buttfeld. Hey Hassan, I haven't made anywhere near as much
money as you have from streaming, so I can't afford to go to
your homeland yet to get the hair transplant, okay? Like you
did. How about you stop hitting me for being bald, you bald [__]
God decided you would be bald and you violated God's will. [__]
you.
That's what he said. [__] got him. I don't know when
we you know, collectively decided that uh regressing into actual
fifth graders
was the sign of strength, but you know, here we are culturally.
Okay. That's really immature. The way you I mean, that's really
immature. My 85 hours in a week on Kaya was very mature. It was
not a fifth grader's work, okay? You calling me bald, you're
a fifth grader.
He's pissed because he had like a three-week news cycle
about Charlotte Schock Collergate. Schock Collergate. Vice President
of the United States
called him a bad person. He just totally lost control of that
narrative. Okay. He lost control of that
That That is probably true.
What? It seems like 2 weeks later he's hanging out with all the
biggest left-wing Democrat influencers that exist, so problem?
Problem? Okay, anyway, I'm going to stop laughing at Hutch's
stream directly and head over to the
live and learn from tonight where I'm hearing that there might
have been some sparks flying, okay? There might have been some
heat applied.
Hutch might not be Pisco's boy anymore. We'll have to see. We'll
keep watching. Wait, why did this not go through? I understand
why they did it. I don't support it. So, it's fair to say you
don't agree with these eight senators voting the way they did,
correct? Okay. I do not agree with the eight senators. I wouldn't
have voted like that, but I'm seeing I'm still seeing a lot of
positives that came out of this fight. So, you're saying that
there's a silver lining here, but to be clear, your position
is
vote no, right? Absolutely, yeah. Okay. I I As you As your fellow
establishment shill, I want to push back on one thing you said,
which was the I I don't see the whole Trump pushing for a filibuster
thing as a tangible win at all. Like I don't I don't think that
Wait, did really move the needle in any direction. Uh the Washington
>> Pisco talking about Hutch's tweets, but Examiner, which
is, you know, right-wing outlet, uh they actually reached out
to each and every Republican senator
uh eight, I think, Republicans didn't didn't get back to them.
So, that's like the group of people that were just afraid to
say anything to piss off Trump, I'm assuming. Uh and only uh
and there were 24
Republican senators that were willing to go on the record
after they lost the election and after Donald Trump has been
pressuring them, they were willing to go on the record and say
we are not in we are not going to support getting rid of the
filibuster. Yeah. So, I think that shows you right there that
we they were never even close to folding on the filibuster, even
though >> Hutch, I don't think they were going to do it.
>> they did, that would have been insanely beneficial to
Democrats and, you know, this is a clown show, this is a Republican
Party, but these are generally like intelligent people. I think
they can understand that if they got rid of the filibuster, that
would have massively
benefited Democrats, in my opinion. Hutch, I was watching your
stream this morning at the gym and I think you said something
that I agree with, which was
Trump I feel like Soy Pill's going to try to save him somehow
here. So, Soy Pill's going to try to soften Hutch's opinion.
That's what he's been doing. He's kind of been [__]
wrangling Hutch for the past couple episodes. I think we'll see
that continue here. >> Trump is so good at, you know, finagling
and and and mobbing his his way through the the party and being
like you have to do this or we're primarying you. And if this
was not enough to get these 24 senators plus however many, it's
just clear that they were not going to fold on this. This is
like, "No, we cannot let the Democrats have a no filibuster,
you know, control next midterm or next presidential election.
They will make Puerto Rico a state. They will make DC a state.
It will [__]
Huh? I hope we do it anyway. Well, yeah, I hope we do, too. We
I guess we're going to need more than 60, but but the idea is
like even Trump couldn't push these people to do this, it seems.
So, I don't know necessarily if that was a win for us. I just
want to say one more thing and then Pisco, you can you can take
over, but I just want to ask you guys, we're all very engaged
in politics. I was definitely aware of the Medicaid cuts when
the one big beautiful bill stuff was being passed.
How many of you guys found out about specifically the tax credits
expiring because of the shutdown fight? I'm not ashamed to raise
my hand and say I didn't know I didn't know they were going to
I didn't know they were going to expire
when they were going to expire until that was told to us, but
I I don't know why they did it. do because it was brought up
during the one big beautiful bill fight that and the CBO even
scored it and talked about how many people are going to lose
their health insurance because of those expiring subsidies. They
talked about that, but definitely the focus back then was on
the Medicaid cuts. And so, when I when I
When I pulled my audience and my audience is super engaged in
politics, if they're watching one of my streams, they're probably
more engaged than like 90% of people that that consume political
stuff.
He Does he think people are there for And in my Trust I've I've
been that guy, Hutch, okay? People are there for Hassan snark
with a little politics flavor to it, okay? As in like when Like
I'll watch these political videos cuz I'm going to watch them
anyway, but when the Hassan snark drops, okay? When I'm when
I When you're going to do drama, you're going to do anti-Hassan
drama. That's like the That's the big thing. That is I'm saying
that as a guy who had that job, okay? The guy who who did that,
who was that guy. I'm just telling you that's what they're there
for. my stream, it was a little less than half didn't know that
about the tax credit issue. And what are we even talking about?
We should like clearly define that just in case anybody in chat
doesn't even know what we're talking about, but like the ARP
that Biden signed into law in 2021, they basically enhanced the
ACA subsidies and they
like ACA subsidies to like a ton of people in the middle-income
bracket and they basically erased costs for a lot of low-income
people that were part of the marketplace or whatever. And they
that expired in 2023, they extended it with the IRA until the
end of this year. And what's happening right now is the Republicans
are just letting that lapse. And so, the fact that like so many
people were made aware of this issue, I think that is valuable.
So, even though we didn't get any concessions and I'm going to
say and then I'll pass it over, I'm sorry. I'm going to say that
I don't agree that they should have given up just yet. I think
they should have stretched it out a little bit longer, but I
am not comfortable with just an indefinite shutdown and just
the amount of pain that that would cause basically defeats the
purpose of what we're fighting for, in my opinion, but Uh I don't
know if you could say Hutch has cost them talent. It's It's just
like a little weird. What are you asking me, Cam? Are you in
in the Discord in case Kweiman or any co-snarkers want to join
later on? Uh I'm in the Discord, but I probably don't want to
do commentary with multiple people in the segment. Um I think
I think I I don't know, we'll see. We'll see.
That's my silver lining. They raised the salience and the awareness
of this issue. This issue This issue will be a liability in January
for Republicans. It's not going away. They're still going to
have to deal with the anger and the outrage from the pain that
people feel. Here's my fundamental problem with the cases that
Hutch and I are just laid out and I agree with a lot of what
they said is those you know, silver linings, those benefits are
independent of the decision that we're evaluating, right? Those
benefits were locked in when the Democrats decided for this to
be an issue and to actually have the shutdown fight. And so,
those benefits are locked in regardless of whether or not you
choose to bend the knee now and cave now. Now, to be clear, every
single person on this live and learn panel has said they are
against what these eight senators did. Not Uh Major Doctor Gasly,
this this
This channel never gets subs because it never gets viewers because
Hutch and Pisco individually stream the the show, right? Like
Pisco streams the show, Hutch streams the show. They're like
a vast majority of the viewership, I believe. And so, I don't
think basically anyone here gets views. Sorry, I I don't think
the the main show gets views while it runs. Not just us, by the
way. Every single one of us says that this was a bad thing to
do. Presumably, it was a bad thing to do for a reason, right?
Presumably, you guys think it was bad to do because of reasons.
And we're not the only ones, right? Gavin Newsom is against it.
J.B. Pritzker is against it. All of the base people in Congress
are against it. Bernie Sanders, etc. etc. etc. The entirety Chuck
Schumer is against it. Uh yeah, the official position of Chuck
Schumer is that he's against it. Jeffries' official position
is that he's against it. So, in order to say that you're in support
of this action, you have to be going against both Jeffries' and
Schumer's official position. And everyone else that Democrats
have been saying are based, not just elected representatives,
Brian Tyler Cohen, Dave Pakman, everyone based is against and
the reason is obvious. The reason is obvious. One, it's a huge
undercut to Democrats' negotiating credibility. Everyone knows
now that the Democrats will bend whenever you just hold hostage,
like Trump is doing right now, illegally withholding SNAP funding,
you can't ask for a more optical benefit for Democrats, where
he's going to the Supreme Court saying I'm allowed to illegally
suspend and not pay out SNAP benefits, even though Congress specifically
allocated contingency funds for these kinds of situations. He
himself, Trump acknowledged that the shutdown was hurting Republicans
because obviously it was, cuz they're in power. Trump acknowledged
Republicans have the power to stop it. And so, why? Why are we
doing this? Why are we giving Trump an out? Why are we, you know,
taking
Yeah, I mean, it's basically all the reasons we've laid out so
far. Yeah. >> responsibility for the shutdown. Now, it
looks like the Democrats were cooking up the shutdown right before
an election. That's what it looks like. Um and and then beyond
that, even if it were the optimal time to drop it right now,
like the optimal time is to right now relent.
Why? Why wouldn't you get a consensus among your caucus? So,
now it looks like a disaster, just like in March, cuz everyone's
yelling at leadership and at these eight scapegoats that they've
put up. This can't be optimal that we have Democrats themselves
like criticizing their own and causing friction right after a
election W. What, we can't have a agreement among the caucus
on messaging after this so that we're all unified? That couldn't
happen even if this were the optimal time to to drop the fight?
And they put out these old geezers who no one is excited about,
who are all going to either retire or or up for re-election not
until 2028. It looks so phony and so fake. And if you believe
Tim Kaine, Tim Kaine who came out and said Uh-oh, Hutch. Is Hutch
aware
that Pisco may be like taking up Hasan's mantle, the guy who
Why is he Why is Pisco criticizing Democrats right now? Why?
Hutch, I feel like Hutch's project
he go after Pisco right now. We're not the only ones behind closed
doors. WHY CAN'T THIS GUY JUST SAY SOMETHING NICE ABOUT DEMOCRATS
right now, Hutch? WHY CAN'T HE DO IT? >> There's more people
who are thankful. That's Tim Kaine, who was probably specifically
chosen as a scapegoat, couldn't take the heat and now is saying,
"Yeah, everyone else is lying to you. That behind the closed
doors, there are more people who are lying to the American people
and their own Democratic base because they don't trust them."
And that's the issue. When Tim Kaine says Oh, quick quick Mantis
drive-by. I think Schumer is hot as I think I think Schumer Mantis
says I think Schumer is hot as Wow.
Incredible stuff.
Incredible stuff. >> There are more like us who knows if
they're getting the truth cuz the fundamentally there's a disconnect
between leadership in the Senate, leadership among the Democratic
establishment, uh here I'm defining that as the leadership in
both Congress, you know, House of Congress, and the voters. And
that's clear. And so, this is a huge fumble, letting the gas
off, and letting Trump have a W when they're responsible, justifiably
responsible, and at the same time not getting your messaging
ducks in a row and signaling that you're lying to the American
people and to your Democratic base. Disaster. There's definitely
more senators. There's definitely more senators and these are
definitely scapegoats. I don't think that's even a question.
I think that what I I really think that what happened is Trump
made it about the filibuster and some some Democrats got cold
feet because fundamentally having a filibuster makes it more
fun and interesting to be a senator and it makes their jobs more
important and it makes their individual votes more meaningful.
And so, I think they decided that this was not
You know what? I'm going to back off here cuz I think um I think,
you know, people just wouldn't have fun as a senator if the filibuster
was gone.
What? Uh something that they were going to tolerate. I think
that it had nothing to do I mean it had something to do with
like SNAP, but I think what tipped it over was that Trump started
to make it about the filibuster and some Democrats got nervous.
And I bet that there's more than eight. I bet that these are
just the eight that they put up. Well, I mean, what's your overall
take on this,
The overall whether it's good or bad that we I I think it's bad
that we stopped it now. I think we should have held out for a
guaranteed vote in both houses. I think that should have been
that what we called it. For how long? How long would you have
been open to keeping the government shut down?
I don't know. I don't have an end date. I mean, I frankly I think
that that's a pretty reasonable
I think that that's a pretty reasonable thing that we could have
gotten eventually. I'm not sure I could give you like
I don't know. A month or two. Another month. Another month. I
just want to say even if you don't agree with like that they're
that it shouldn't be indefinite, I think that you should be willing
to do it indefinitely, just to be clear. That's where I stand.
But even if you don't, we should at least have an agreement within
the caucus of when that date is. So, it's not like in the middle
of Sunday night, right? In Sunday night, the dead of night, so
that people don't eight to the specific amount of senators that
you needed to get over the filibuster and all of them are hand-selected.
Couldn't you if there has to be
Hey, uh one second.
Okay. Um
Thank you. Okay. Um
Hold on, one second.
Oh, uh quick meme from Top Bronson. That's what I was going to.
Here we go. Quick quick meme. Okay. All right, I'll hit play
again. a day end and I think it should be indefinite. Couldn't
we have agreed on it? Couldn't we have done it in a way that
it's not like this sneaky thing that Wait wait wait wait hold
on before you jump hand-selected.
We should we should get We should get Soy Bella in here cuz let's
get everybody's take and then we can do the free-for-all.
Yeah, I mean, my thing is like what was the really the point
of the shutdown if if you weren't going to get any guarantees
in the first place. I agree with IRI. I mean, this is optically
good for the Democrats, but like keep doing it, right? Like this
was hurting Republicans. They were hemorrhaging support. Like
if Chuck Schumer was right about the fact that we need to do
this when Trump is at uh all-time low, then keep it up because
the longer this goes, the more people suffer, the more they're
going to blame the people in power who are not allowing, you
know, the Americans to have what most people want. And people
like Newsom and I think other Democratic governors could do the
thing where they say, "Look, we're going to utilize our National
Guard. We're going to utilize our state's resources to alleviate
the the SNAP you know, repercussions because we give a [__]
about these people, but we are not going to stop the shutdown
because we need to have some sort of win, some sort of guarantee."
And right now it looks like we didn't really get anything guaranteed.
That That upsets me a little bit. And like I said, I'm I'm open
to the idea that this could work out in the end. I was uh you
know, skeptical of the Schumer idea in March and and and IRI
and and Hutch proved me wrong on that. Uh so, I'm happy there,
but I don't know if this is going to hold out to midterms. I
don't know if people are going to remember it as much. Whoops,
I was muted. Um yeah, I was muted there. That was me actually
being
I was saying we're getting close to the part where this is going
to start popping off. All right. Get ready. It's going to start
popping off right away. >> but I'm very skeptical of it.
>> We needed the prelude so we had the context, all right?
You guys think it's going to depress turnout? IRI, go ahead.
Sorry, I cut you off before. No, I want to say Pisco was nodding
along to what you're saying cuz I agree with you on most of that
stuff, man. But here's the thing. It was always a lifeline to
extend the ACA subsidies for Trump. This would have been a blessing
for him. This is now going to be a liability and they're going
to get completely over people's health insurance premiums going
up. A lot of the people took Okay, wasn't Hold on. Wasn't wasn't
it a gig a liability to have food stamps not being paid out?
Like that was a massive liability. Thank you. I think that was
a massive liability. No?
Is that not a way bigger liability?
give advantage to these subsidies in red states like Florida
and Texas. And politically, it's a gift for the Democrats to
not extend the subsidies. I care about my fellow Americans, so
I wanted to see it get done and I thought it was worth fighting
for. But in the end, if it doesn't work out, it's a huge gift
for the Democrats going to the midterms and now we positioned
ourselves Okay, so that the worst-case scenario, you've just
brought forward the worst-case scenario. You've accepted the
worst-case scenario, which is those don't get passed.
This is strategically
Like you should be upset. You just chose the worst-case scenario
before even like trying to ride this out at all. Bills as the
leader to bring down people's health insurance costs. So, we
will benefit politically tremendously. The thing is, the reason
why I don't take heart from that, IRI, and I think it's Giving
me giving me like a silver lining that might be there doesn't
mean that this was a good decision. Cut my arm off and then go,
"Yeah, but if you think about it, you could have gotten like
frostbite in that arm. It could have gotten necrotic and then
spread to the rest of your body and killed you. So, like think
about it. You kind of didn't want that arm, did you?" True. No,
I did. I did want that arm. or not, right? Like that The fact
that Democrats raised this issue, I agree, that's really good.
And that's They did bring that But the thing is, that's true
regardless of the direction you take to keep fighting or and
and having your bottom line that you said publicly. And again,
you should never like publicly have a bottom line and then go
back on it cuz then you lose. That's one of the reasons why Trump
it's taco, right? Cuz Trump will set out a bottom line and no
one really believes it, right? Like and it's like whatever. So,
so we have no credibility. But the thing that you're talking
about, the benefits electorally, were going to happen whether
or not we continued. I disagree. If we didn't pick this fight,
it wouldn't have happened. I I just say I'll give you the When
I say continue, I mean at the after the shutdown fight, when
we had this fight, right? The benefits to electorally of the
strategy, right? are going to be priced in regardless of whether
you take this vote, right? So, if you But maybe we would have
got what Ryan is saying. We would have got a commitment for the
House or anything further. Any further advancement of expanding
extending the ACA subsidies would have benefited Trump and the
Republicans if they actually got it, is what I'm saying. For
the record, I don't think that they would have ever actually
voted for that. The only reason I think that it would have been
nice to get a vote commitment in the House. I would have been
comfortable
I guess I should clarify. I don't think that the Democrats should
feel any obligation to vote to fund this government. If the Republicans
want to continue governing like this, they can use the filibuster
and and do it by themselves for all I care. I really don't think
that it's uh the Democrats should feel an obligation. Okay. Republicans
want to offer some compromise, which is what the filibuster,
which I don't really support in principle in the first place,
is intended to do, then um you know, we can talk about it and
I would have been comfortable with funding the government if
they had given a guaranteed vote in the Senate and a guaranteed
vote in the House because then at least we can get everyone on
the record. And then we can campaign on an actual vote. Um so,
that's why I'm disappointed with where they chose to where they
chose to have it now. But I don't think the Republicans were
ever actually going to vote to extend the subsidies. Wait, put
that back up on the screen. That was very triggering.
>> You know why I put that there. My health premium has
tripled, but at least I'm aware of this issue now.
>> I mean, we can have differences of opinion about the
strategy around the shutdown. That's fine. That doesn't trigger
me at all. I understand why Pisco's upset. I disagree that it's
tenable to you know, be prepared to have it play out indefinitely,
but I understand where he's coming from and I'm not even I'm
not even going to say that there's zero like political logic
to that. But just to be absolutely clear, the Republicans are
in control of the government right now. They control the executive
branch, they control the legislative branch. The Democrats do
not have the power to extend these ACA tax credits. That power
rests entirely with the Republicans. And if they refuse to negotiate
during a shutdown, that does not absolve them from being 1,000%
responsible for these tax credits expiring. And if you're one
of these guys that's going out here and making the case that
the Democrats are responsible for this happening, you are you're
being you're doing free MAGA >> Hutch, Hutch, let me defend
the guy. They're not saying this is Democrats' fault. They're
saying this doesn't feel like a win from the Democrats. I wish
the Democrats did more, not
Did Pasco just have like a meltdown? >> fault. They're
saying this doesn't feel like a win from the Democrats. I wish
the Democrats did more, not
Hold on. Do I need to grab the pose
Is he like he's been psychically damaged by Hutch's
He's been psychically damaged. HUTCH, WHAT ARE YOU DOING? STOP.
HUTCH is like Psyduck, okay? He's actually doing psychic damage
right
Will Pasco ever recover? I wish the Democrats did more, not the
Republicans are you know totally absolved of any and all blame
for that. I don't think this is your Democrat >> No, they're
just but they're also like dismissing they're dismissing the
value of raising awareness of an issue like this, which is to
me kind of ridiculous. I think that this is this is triggering
me, Hutch. I'm sorry. Sorry to interrupt you. I I understand
what you're saying that there are some [laughter] people who
seem to think that like magically Democrats can do this, but
I I think that you're not taking it at the strongest that argument.
That argument I think is based on force them to make an unpopular
decision. You have them by the balls because there are three
options. Option one, continue the shutdown, which
>> them by the ball.
Hutch is like oh [__] I just I just woke him up.
Option one, [__] Continue the shutdown, which they're
being blamed for. Winner for Democrats. Option number two,
>> We should pause on that. Bend on I just wanted to get
all the three options people see. One is continue the shutdown,
two is bend on the premiums and bend on the subsidies. Option
number three, nuke the filibuster. Force your opponent to do
one of those tough decisions. But we didn't do that. And so that's
where the frustration I think comes from. So for the latter two
things that you that you said, they were they gave no indication
whatsoever that they were even slightly bending on getting rid
of the filibuster or making concessions around the tax credits.
So that leaves us with the first one that you said, which is
just let them drag this government shutdown out for as long as
possible. >> being blamed for it. >> I understand
that. I understand that. But we should be specific about what
that means because it's true that the courts compelled Trump
to pay out the SNAP benefits from the emergency funds. Those
emergency funds that we have is $4 billion.
It costs $8 billion every month to fund SNAP. So those funds
are going to dry up in 2 weeks or in a month if he does like
half payments. And at that point, we're to we all Guess what?
Guess what, Hutch? Who's party in power right Who's party in
power? Hey Hutch, why do you think Biden lost the 2024 election?
I forget, was it something like well the economy was doing bad
and the party in power gets blamed for like the state of the
country.
Was that why? Is it I feel like I remember Hutch saying that.
One, two, one. It sounds like Trump just wants to run your country
into the ground and unfortunately, what you have to do is understand
the long-term ramification ramifications of letting that happen
so that he can't run your country into the ground in a third
term.
Let people see how terrible these people are at governing.
Hey, they don't want to give us the tax credits we want on this
one tiny thing?
Okay. Well, I guess Trump's willing to shut down the government.
Trump's willing to run your country into the
Let them go out and explain why it's actually Democrats' fault.
Why they couldn't just make a decision and have the government
come back. Let them explain that. are talking about 41 million
people who are uh 130% under the uh poverty level that rely on
these benefits literally rely on these benefits to survive. And
I feel like it is an insanely privileged position for I'm not
going to you know assume anybody's situation, but I think you
know like we're all probably like okay.
I don't know like are any of us going to lose benefits because
of the shutdown?
I I What do we mean by benefits? Like like unemployment and like
and SNAP? Anything that we Are you going to lose any benefits
because of the government shutdown? 100%
What I mean just you need to survive.
Okay. I feel like it's really easy for us to be like Democrats
should hold the line and fight when
I I'm sorry. Every single decision that's been made on this,
every single decision that's been made like
I know we're kind of letting Trump win, but have you thought
about like how we just have to protect regular people from how
bad he It's like hey, every time you guys make that decision,
you guys look better or sorry, Trump looks better. Trump looks
like the master negotiator. Trump looks like he's winning.
Every single time. Unfortunately,
you have to sometimes have a longer range a longer distance political
calculus going
He will end his political career. He will end his political party
if he maintains this shutdown. And he is maintaining the shutdown.
They're doing it over ACA premium tax credits, right? That costs
nothing. You cannot say well, actually because every bad thing
you're saying is going to be blamed on Trump
And Hutch, whether or not we specifically as commentators are
in the class of people Um Wombo Combinator,
once people aren't able to eat, once they're not able to like
feed themselves, they snap out of it real quick. Real real real
quick. And guess what the people who aren't eating? They You
don't understand the the the ripple ramification the ripple out
effect of what's happening here, right? Suddenly people are going
to have to go to their family members and say hey, I can't feed
myself. Right? It's not just the people on SNAP. There are a
tremendously high number of people. It It would shock you to
know how many people are on SNAP. Obviously, $8 billion a month
to pay
They will all have to go to family members, to churches, to food
shelter, to uh not food shelters, but uh
like food banks and stuff. They'll have to go to all these places.
You will see this ripple out massively.
Every single person in America is going to be affected. And it
will all be blamed on Trump. It will be blamed on Trump because
Trump is the guy who can make anything happen. It's it it it
sucks to make that calculus, but you have to do it.
You have to do it. You just literally have to. who's being helped
is irrelevant to the actual argument. You're just making an argument
that like individuals are privileged and be talking about this.
>> No, no, no. It's easy for you to make the case that
these benefits should end when you're not relying on them to
survive. That's my point. >> It's easy for you to make
the case when the premiums don't affect you because I don't know
what the [__] like it's easy for you to make any
case. Like what kind of argument is that? You're saying that
like somehow So So if I were poor So So So if I were really really
poor and making this argument, what would you say? Assume that.
Why would we get into this in the specifics of you as like individuals?
Wait. Hold on, Hutch. Are you telling me if I was getting SNAP,
you would like take me more seriously? You would just totally
be emotionally manipulated? Is that what you're saying, Hutch?
>> Why is that relevant to the argument? >> That's
That's fine, but I I'd be very curious to know what everybody
who relies on these benefits, how they feel about the shutdown.
That's what I want to know. >> This is like classic identity
politics, >> to be sad cuz I know people that are on SNAP.
I know people who work for the government who are being furloughed
and are We're actually they've been asked to come back to work
without pay. So they're actually working for free right now.
They're not even just getting you know you know put out of work
and not getting paid. And these people are on board with hey,
yeah, this is Hey Pasco. Hey Pasco. Do you ever Do Do you know
that there are kids starving in Africa right now?
Do you really think it's okay to keep the government shutdown?
There are kids starving in Africa right now, Pasco.
Right now. It's hurting me, but ultimately I want this fight
to win. Now I don't know what the consensus is. Obviously people
are going to get hurt, but yeah, it is easier to say if it doesn't
hurt you directly. >> way, that's every single government
There will be people hurt. There will be people who rely on benefits.
Hutch is saying actually we should just concede every single
time. We should show that we will concede if it's going to affect
a significant portion of Americans. We will concede every time.
We will never negotiate. We will never try to apply any pressure.
He is not just once. He's He's infinity
He's infinity
He's crazy. >> same way like Hutch or we could you know
throw it back from last week and be like well Hutch, it's easy
for you to say I'll vote for a pro-segregationist Dem to stop
a Republican cuz you're not black. Like yeah, but that doesn't
Dude, Hutch is getting Hutch is getting filled. Hutch is airtight
right now. He's getting filled in every hole by the members of
this podcast. That's a disgusting visual. I know I don't want
to put that in your mind, but Jesus Christ. Why did Soy Belt
to come in and point out the hypocrisy, too? element of the situation
is any less valid. It just means it's easier for you, which is
true, but it doesn't invalidate your opinion. So Yeah, it's literally
irrelevant. I It's mostly irrelevant, but but the question is
like the ultimate question is Well, it's I I mostly irrelevant,
but I Wait, what is the relevant Wait, wait, What is the relevance
to Hutch? Pasco, Pasco, he's your boy. Hutch is your boy Hutch
is your boy. Don't do this to him, okay?
Uh Pasco's heart rate, Hutch's heart >> The what the relevant
part of this is is how much are we willing to how much are we
willing to let the American people hurt to get this win? Because
if we don't say If we don't say what is the consensus we're reaching
to and we don't know how long it's going to take, will we just
let the Republicans lose and lose and lose and lose? More More
specifically, people that are not Yeah, like More specifically,
other people. This is a conversation about how are we How How
far are we willing to go in terms of allowing other people to
so that we get a political win. Cuz you're thinking in the short
You're You're thinking in the short term. You're thinking and
this is why you'll always lose and why Democrats who think this
way will always lose. It's actually way better than I thought
it was going to be.
It's so much better than I thought it was going to be.
If you get a political win. Cuz you're thinking in the short
you're thinking in the short term. You're thinking and this is
why you'll always lose, and why Democrats who think this way
will always lose. Is if all you're thinking about is the fight
tomorrow is about what you're like then you're never going to
in the long term be able to resist Trump or be able to resist
the authoritarianism. Cuz you're not playing the long game. You're
not playing I'm not thinking about that. I'm literally here Trump
is a fascist. Trump is like an evil guy who doesn't care about
the average American and like will do anything to maintain power
and get his way. And Hutch is like, "Oh,
we should we should totally give in to him every single time
that he threatens the country in some way. We should just give
in. How'd that work out for Europe in the 1930s, Hutch? How did
it work out?" Thinking about the cost. I'm thinking about the
actual cost of what does it look like when 41 million poor people
lose benefits that they rely on to survive. So if the Republicans
conditioned if the if the Republicans conditioned if if Republicans
conditioned is a
It's just
>> It's just the Sudetenland, guys. It's just the Sudetenland.
It's not really not a big deal. Okay. If Republicans conditioned
reopening the government on eliminating entirely Medicaid, would
you vote for that?
Hold on. I'm a little distracted by chat. Ask the question again.
If Republicans hypothetically, not real hypothetically, conditioned
reopening the government on eliminating Medicaid entirely, would
you vote for that? No. BUT 41 MILLION PEOPLE WILL STARVE, HUTCH.
HOW COULD HOW DARE
I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS A bad That was a bad hypothetical cuz getting
rid of Medicaid is like literally worse. So Hutch has an easy
out here. It's actually a Pisco L, I think, on this point. It's
not a good point, actually. But it's funny. Hypothetically.
Hold on. What are the chat messages? Apparently there's some
chat messages.
That's freaking ghoulish. He can't really believe this. Ask Republicans
that same question. This isn't a political win, Hutch. It literally
is people's health On eliminating entirely Medicaid, would you
vote for that? Hmm.
Hold on. I'm a little distracted by chat. Ask the question again.
If Republicans hypothetically, not real Why is Pisco so upset
about people eating? He will never go hungry. Hypothetically,
conditioned reopening the government on eliminating Medicaid
entirely, would you vote for that? No. BUT 41 MILLION PEOPLE
WILL STARVE, HUTCH. HOW COULD HOW DARE YOU? HOW DARE YOU DO THIS?
YOU'RE TALKING about eliminating
He should have He needed a more middle-of-the-road one, okay?
A program that millions of Americans rely on. So it's like We're
kicking 17 million people out of all here, you know what I mean?
That's not what we're dealing with right now, though. Those aren't
the two options. We're not getting rid of Medicaid. The point
is everyone has a line. Everyone has a line that that where they're
going to say, "Yeah, I'm going to fund this government or I'm
not going to fund this government." And where I'm going to vote
for something or not. You just said you had a line. And the question
is
is this a justifiable line? And this is a line that Democrats
should should fall on. And I thought we went into this fight
I thought we went into this fight we we picked this issue specifically
because
we thought that it was worth fighting and dying on that hill.
If that wasn't our position with respect to this issue, we should
not have taken this fight. IF WE DID NOT ASSESS That's a That
is a good point as well. That is why it's a failure of leadership.
Hey, if you guys aren't ready to hold out for this thing, if
this is not important enough to you to hold out for, I need to
know going into this cuz I need to know that you will stand behind
me right now. Right? When you're the leader in the Senate, like
Chuck Schumer needs to know, "Hey, John Fetterman, I get that
you have no principles. I get that you're a total piece of [__]
But will you stand behind me on this?"
And not knowing that and getting like totally on by eight senators
crossing the the line, right? To get the government funded again,
that's terrible leadership. Just in case you guys are wondering
why you should be mad at Chuck
even though he actually was against this this deal, right?
At time equals zero that this was the fight worth having, and
this was the issue worth fighting on. Okay, Fetterman was maybe
always against it. Got it. Why why fight on it? I am sympathetic
to that argument. The argument that and this is Pacman's argument,
too. He was arguing the same thing. Like if you're not, you know,
why'd you even pick the fight in the first place? I brought up
The reason I brought up before I asked you Sure, whether or not
Schumer was really against the deal or not, okay? Whether or
not he was really against it or not, I'm telling you you could
blame it on him no matter what. Guys, like how many of you guys
were made aware of the tax credits expiring? Was it everybody
on this panel? Like I don't know. The same same question for
everybody's chat that's currently watching. How many of you guys
learned about this issue because of the shutdown? There is value
in that. You can make the argument that it the shutdown was not
worth increasing awareness and salience, but there is value to
that. Hutch just pulled the I This is my least favorite I literally
lose my mind when I hear people make this excuse, okay? If you're
going to try to make the excuse of,
"Well, maybe I'm wrong, but at least it started a conversation."
Shut the [__] up. Shut the [__] up.
Oh, I hate this excuse so much.
Then take the deal after a week. This deal was available or like
in the first
Who was going to give this deal over? I'm sympathetic
Okay. So so so like the thing is we And and once those premiums
comes out, you can start doing your media [__] on
it. Then then take the deal in the first week. And why? It almost
justifies some of the Republican talking points on it. They're
letting this like if you're not willing to die for it, then it
undermines your entire position staking this out as a long term
You're not dying for it. You're sacrificing 41 million poor people.
That's not you dying. That's other people dying. Yeah, but also
I I I I just want to So So we're going to deal with this relevance
point, okay? Hutch. Is it relevant
Okay, you don't want to answer You don't want to answer this
question because Keep going. So So this is what This is what
Hutch is doing right now. Hutch is basically saying, instead
of actually arguing the merits of should we do this or what the
import of it, Pisco lives in New York City. Pisco is Hold on.
I'm going to back this up. I want to listen to that
I want to listen to it again.
You're not dying for it. You're sacrificing 41 million poor people.
Hutch is my boy.
Hutch is my boy. I can't I can't I can't I have to be calm. Remain
calm. Hutch is your boy.
your boy.
Remain calm. Remain calm. Remain calm. Hutch is your That's not
you dying. That's other people dying. Yeah, but also
I I I I just want to So So we're going point, okay? Hutch. Is
it relevant Okay, you don't want to answer You don't want to
answer this question because Keep going. So So this is what This
is what Hutch is doing right now. Hutch is basically saying,
instead of actually arguing the merits of should we do this or
what the import of it, Pisco lives in New York City. Pisco is
not poor. And so Pisco is an elitist, and Pisco is entitled,
and so you shouldn't listen to Pisco because Pisco is not the
one dying on the street. That's what you're trying to do right
now. That's why I'm taking this so aggressively. I don't know.
Wait.
Wait. What is
Listen, I I would give Hutch an L on this. But that is like You
can say that's not what I'm saying.
But that is ultimately if you're going to keep hitting the the
other person with that. That is ultimately what it comes down
to, right? The other person doesn't care. I care. Listen, they
may not care. You may not care. You're not dying, right? But
I I do care. So I I think it's, you know, it's reasonable. The
relevance other than that is what you're saying. There is a very
real cost. We need to get away from the abstract.
You could like actually filter down all of the most viewers on
this show just through the chat. It's what you're saying. There
is a very
Pisco's 41 people billion people for this shutdown? Pisco's politically
ignorant. Did he suddenly forget about the attention economy
and controlling the narrative?
This Pisco dude is an idiot.
I don't
I don't know what Where's the disagreement? Where are you disagreeing?
Very real cost. We need to get away from the abstract and talk
about This is Hutch in DGG chat. Well, if it's DGG chat, let
me tell you, you're going to be embarrassed cuz I think even
if Destiny were to hate Pisco, which I don't believe he does,
but even if he were to hate Pisco, he wouldn't go against him
here cuz Pisco's very much not afraid to call somebody out who's
just going to lie. Nobody can take Hutch's side here. That That's
why you see nobody stepping in cuz Hutch Hutch is used to having
certain people have his back. He probably sees the chat supporting
him, right? He probably does see the chat supporting him, and
he doesn't know that he needs to back down right now. That he's
just wrong from like every angle. He is wrong. He's totally wrong.
Everyone else can see it, but Hutch cannot. It's very interesting.
Up the very real cost. And nobody's talking about that. Of all
the people that are enraged on social media, I don't see anybody
talking about what would have happened if this would have prolonged,
and then 41 million people just wet Bernie Sanders So Bernie
Sanders isn't internalizing the cost. So wait wait. Bernie Sanders
is doing that. Gavin Newsom is doing that. J.B. Pritzker is is
doing that. Um
Hakeem Jeffries is doing that, and Chuck Schumer are doing that.
Is that Oh, [__] Oh, [__]
Hutch just realized
he's not just critiquing Pisco's position. He's critiquing actual
Democrats' positions, too. Oh, now he's now he's split. His mind
is split. J.B. Pritzker is is doing that.
Hakeem Jeffries is doing that, and Chuck Schumer are doing that.
Is that right? You're saying they're not internalizing the cost?
They don't care about Cuz they're rich,
Aren't you appealing to authority right
He's actually not. He's not appealing to authority at all. He's
literally not. No. No. No. He's literally not. He's saying, "You
You under He's saying He's literally checking if you've thought
about what you're saying. Have you thought about the fact that
if you're critiquing me for saying this, you are also critiquing
all of these people?"
He's not saying he's right because of it. He's saying, "Do you
understand that you are also saying these people are all wrong,
and they cannot actually process that 42 million people are going
to be off of SNAP?"
He's not saying, "Well, these guys agree with me, so I'm right."
That's not what's happening. No, it's Wait, wait, you're you're
making the argument that So, I'm associating myself with all
the base Democrats who are saying, "Cowardice, bending the knee."
And even Hakeem Jeffries and Schumer in their official position.
But you're not engaging what I just said. >> What am I
not engaging with? Cuz you're saying, "Oh, it's right because
a bunch of people think it's right." I'm telling you like, "Okay,
if By the way, a lot of people in this space, this is why you
know Hutch isn't really built for this,
>> A lot of people in this space understand what Pisco
is saying immediately because it's not being confused. Like it's
not confusing. He's not saying it in a stupid way, right? Like
Hutch doesn't understand that he is not able to process in real
time what's happening.
It's like you see somebody who is like blind and Pisco is like
throwing tennis balls at this guy and they're all
hitting square in the middle of his bald dome, right? We're watching
Pisco beat up a blind guy, just throw tennis balls at him from
across the room. It's kind of [__] up, but then you
realize that Hutch is just like I don't know. It is actually
kind of [__] up when you think about it that But
that's basically what this conversation is. No, [clears throat]
no, We're all like but hold on. No, no, no, realistically, I'm
not the bad person. IRI and the Soy Pillar bad people, okay?
Cuz they see Hutch getting pinged in the forehead with these
tennis balls and they keep inviting him back week after week
to a show that's about catching tennis balls thrown at your head.
That's not my fault, that's their fault, okay? They're the people
who are monetizing this poor man and his disability.
I do it. Dude, dude, no, no. You're saying What you're saying
Pisco, wait, wait. So, Hutch, you said if going wrong, but did
you say people are not talking about the cost that of what will
be affected if we continue the shutdown, correct? >> Yeah, I
don't think people are talking about it enough. Like some people
are mentioning it in the abstract. leaders of this shutdown who
voted no to end the shutdown are saying, "We understand the consequences."
People like Gavin Newsom and Pritzker and Schumer, especially
Newsom to my knowledge is like, "I'm going to personally alleviate
those things because I think it's worth helping these people
using that we shouldn't have to to continue this fight." Right,
Pisco? Yes, essentially that the Oh, that makes it like so much
worse, too. If a bunch of If a bunch of damn governors are like,
"Listen, we're going to unlock state funds to help all the people
affected by the snap losses, we're actually going to activate
government funds, our own state government funds to do this and
make sure that this is important, we need to stand on this."
And you still come out as the Democrats?
That's fine. This accusation of privilege, which is what Hutch
is doing. Like right now, it is clear. He's saying, "Pisco, you
don't understand the cost because you're not in the streets and
you're not homeless." That's what Hutch is doing right now to
me and I'm saying, Wait on a second, sorry, my my headphones.
If it's the case that the leaders of this movement are also,
you know, you know, not on the streets, but they have the same
position I do, would you make that same accusation to Gavin Newsom?
Would you make that same accusation to Hakeem Jeffries? Would
you make that same accusation It depends on what their position
is. If their position is keep it going indefinitely, then yeah,
I would say I would say to every single one of those people like,
"I don't know if it makes sense to to to fight for, you know,
what what what are we talking about? We're talking about like
lowering health care for low to low middle income earners." And
in that fight, we are
This like this really just depends. That's not what you're talking
about. What you're talking about is "Okay, I want something small
as a concession to my side to continue funding the government.
In the same way that we make concessions to Republicans before
on some issues, right, to keep the government funded when we
were in power, we want similar concessions back to us. We want,
hey, you continue this tax credit, this ACA tax credit, okay?
You're going to keep doing that, the the the credit that brings
down people's
Okay? Please, please keep doing that and then we can fund your
government.
The same thing we gave you, you should give back to us. It's
only fair and we're actually going to stand on this. And they
go, "No, we don't want reciprocity. No, we don't want to do that.
No, that we're going to we're going to let people starve."
They're Then and then the Democrats say back, "Okay, I mean,
if you're if you're going to do that, then okay, I guess we'll
see how that works out for you."
You Why would you let yourself be painted as the bad guy in that
scenario who has to make it stop? This is This is literally and
I hate to use the most I hate to this topic, okay? The be, you
know, do the whole internet Oh, we're on the internet, we're
going to do comparisons to hate, but this is unironically just
the appeasement argument. You can't appease these people who
give nothing back. You cannot appease here. You can't do it.
You shouldn't do it and it's insane that they allowed it. They
are willing to, you know, >> Well, I say allowed it, obviously
those eight senators could have done this on their own. Seems
like a lot of people have a a lot some reason to believe that
those eight senators might not have anything to lose. They might
not really
you know, by the by the time 3 years from now when they're actually
getting elected or they're up for election there might not be
that much talk about this anymore. benefits away from low-income
people. So
so the dividing line the dividing line between elitists out of
touch, not understanding the cost is my proposition that it be
indefinite even though you have no reason to think that Gavin
Newsom or Pritzker had a different position and where they did
not signal that they had an end date because of course you wouldn't
signal that if you were in a negotiation like this. Right. How
am I saying That makes me out of touch, but not them out of touch.
You're getting so hung up on the out of touch thing, though.
No, no, no, you're getting You you brought it up. You You brought
it up and and and hang on a second. So, the relevance of that
point of you're not poor, you're not the one
Tell me what the relevance of that is. It's basically saying
you're out of touch and you don't you're not internalizing the
cost of the shutdown. Because it's easier to offer up other people
to have to make a sacrifice like this. That's my point. Wait,
why is that point relevant to whether or not what we should do?
That it's easier Yeah, I grant it. It's easier to offer up other
people's suffering. That's That's true of everybody. But I'm
sorry, what is the
Uh actually, because of the median income, I think nobody over
the median income should ever be able to be in government, Hutch.
What do you think of that policy? Because those people who are
in government and voting on things don't understand the suffering
that most people must go through in the world.
And you should only be able to make political decisions if you
understand that suffering. Isn't that a good idea, Hutch? Why
Why isn't that a good idea, Hutch? of that point.
It's not relevant. Because it informs the larger discussion that's
happening right now. In what way? How does it make it more or
less likely to I am making the point that I think people should
be talking more about the specific cost. That's what I'm saying.
You're making a point that your reason you're not talking about
the government shutdown cost to me. The reason you're not doing
it is because you're not on the streets. Isn't that what you're
doing? Bro, this is like 20 minutes of litigating your hurt feelings.
Can we You're You're in an argument where somebody's arguing
2 + 2 is 5, right? And you're getting upset because they won't
And then when you call them out, they go, "Yeah, you're just
a you're you're like They give you They just totally gaslight
you. They totally make up some reason why you're wrong, why you
shouldn't be upset." Right? And then when you're like re-litigating
when you're trying to litigate why they just said that weird
thing about you that obviously they should take back he goes,
"Um it's kind of weird that you're just you're you're just mad
right now. You're You're feelings are hurt, actually. Um it's
so weird. We spent 20 minutes arguing about your feelings. Isn't
that Why would we do that, Pisco?" We let some Okay, wait. Ryan
Gatti is the most neutral person. He's literally in the middle
of all of us right now. Ryan, your thoughts on this. I am. So,
I think
it is making an important point about
there is a human cost. Why Why is it an important point? Just
explain why it's an important point. Or, I mean, explain why
it's relevant here. Explain why it's a good idea to bring it
up. Explain why. Explain why you should be making that point.
It's like
you can think about that,
but what you have to actually think about is all of the other
times with all these regimes, what Trump might be blowing up
by continuing this fight. This is This is literally
Okay, hold on.
Let me cook. I don't think this is
Is this not the Oh, well, it's really bad for us to fund Ukraine
because
that keeps them in a war where they're losing hundreds of thousands
of grown men every year. And just think about it, you're not
going to war, actually, Democrats. You're not going to war. Why
should we fund Ukraine? Why should we fund Ukraine right now
when it's like, bro,
it's an incredibly effective Actually, this is my only point.
It's the most effective cost
to benefit ratio that you've ever witnessed, okay? With the Ukraine
case, you get to fund just a little bit of money, a little bit
of you unused munitions over to Ukraine and you get Russia's
entire war economy spun up having to try to keep their fight
going, right?
That's the same thing that's happening here. You are I understand
it seems terrifying that you're you're costing people snap benefits,
but this is the lowest cost you'll ever get to destroy Trump's
reputation. It's the It's the most effective way you could destroy
Trump's reputation ever and Trump won't admit it. Trump won't
surrender. Trump won't say, "No, no, no, you can keep the Donbas."
He won't say it, right? He won't give back the
And you have to You have to
take the territory back, right? You have to. It's like a moral
imperative that if as long as people are willing to have that
fight, you have to do it right now. You have to stand on this.
uh there's a whole other thing with Ukraine that would apply
here, too, but I'm not going to I'm not going to keep going on
it. It's just like this is This is the line. This is where you
stand up. You stand tall on this cuz it's the best example It's
the best chance you've ever had at hurting this person politically.
And if it comes at that cost, that
But there will be greater costs for not defeating this movement
sooner. So this. I mean, there's a People will hurt the longer
this goes on. At the same time,
that's politics.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, and also it's like negotiating for a ceasefire
or something when Russia's just going to go back, retool, rearm,
and come back and [__] invade a year later. Exactly.
To an extent, that's politics.
And and I I want to be really careful about where we're putting
the agency
Because to the extent that
to the extent
that people are hurt by the shutdown, the Republicans could end
it tomorrow. Their ideological commitment to the
is not
uh does not absolve them of responsibility for the fact that
they control the government. I mean, in my opinion. I think that
that's the case. So, I is there a point at which Democrats should
say like no, no, you know, you're doing you're hurt you know,
your inability to run the government is hurting too much. We
have to, you know, reopen the government. Probably so. I don't
know what that point is. The official position of the Democratic
Party should um should be uh that it that will continue indefinitely.
Um And let me add to that That should be the public position.
you know, the Republicans will just hold starving people as a
hostage every time. Right. Uh Yeah, you are infinity
in this exact thing in this exact scenario. You are infinity
right now. But yeah, as long as you have as long as you can like
hold and by the way, SNAP benefits are an example of something
with a continuing resolution. They will be up every single time,
right? SNAP benefits will run out for every continuing resolution,
no? Cuz they're just based on the next budget for the government.
If you haven't passed a budget, if you haven't passed any continuing
resolution, they're they're up every single time. So, this is
an infinity chip that they have. They can just hold out to this
point where it starts to affect SNAP,
And so, you just pick the hills you actually are willing to die
on, I guess. That that's kind of my take on this, Hutch, is like
yes, I understand this is there's a human cost to this, but like
with the agency of who is who are the people fighting not to
pay SNAP? It's not Democrats because they're continuing the shutdown.
It's the guy going to the Supreme Court and saying, "Make me
not have to pay SNAP." >> that. And and I I know you're
not I don't I'm not I'm preaching to the choir here, but my point
is this almost feels like the inverse of the Democrat blame graph
where it's like, "Why are we saying that well, this is a human
cost that the Democrats are imposing and not hey, we can continue
to blame this on Republicans and they should have this held at
their feet." >> That's not the position. Just to be clear.
Well, sure. Okay. I put the blame mostly on the Trump administration,
but to the extent that Democrats have the power to uh make sure
that 41 million people don't lose this these benefits. And it's
not just SNAP, by the way. There's also WIC for like single moms.
There's also we we give out um assistance [laughter] to millions
of people to pay their rent each month. We give Uh listen, we
have to be the party that cares about people. Unfortunately,
Hutch, you were the party that cares about people and it turns
out the people can't see it. You have to you have to let them
see it.
Listen, this is pain that's required, unfortunately. I wish it
wasn't. I wish people could just go, "Oh, Trump clearly doesn't
give a [__] about human beings." That'd be cool.
If they could do that, they clearly can't. about assistance to
people to pay their energy bills each month. You also have like
federal workers that are furloughed. I mean, this is so much
bigger than just SNAP. You know, like if Yeah, why would you
vote no, Hutch? That's that's pretty privileged of you to vote.
Wait, so you you you I I understand that you're not taking Wait,
I I I I I I understand Wait, I I understand that you're not taking
the position that you would do it >> I'm really sorry.
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait a second. So, I understand
you're not taking the Wait wait wait, I just want to I just want
to make my point. So, I understand you're you're taking I I No,
no, I I'm I understand that you're saying that you would do it
indefinitely. >> Wait, I want to finish the point. >> hear
him say he's sorry? >> wait wait wait wait. Yes, I did
hear him. Yes, I did hear him. I take it back. I'm sorry. Isn't
So, isn't it the case that I take it back. Unfortunately,
you said eight other things before you took it back.
You said eight other things and now Pisco is mad. He's very mad
at you. Cuz you said a bunch of instead of just admitting you
said something stupid to begin with. The machine can't stop once
it started up, okay, Hutch? You're in trouble. You're in trouble.
>> were to vote no now, that's a privileged position cuz
even if it were for two or three weeks, you're not the one actually
suffering not having those benefits,
Well, I you lost me. I don't understand the question. Isn't that
privileged? You're not actually internalizing the cost since
you said, right? You would vote okay. >> I'm a hypocrite.
I'm sorry. Good point. Can I Pisco, I want to call you out on
something. You you said something very dangerous, in my opinion.
You said these guys were handpicked
to be the guys who
>> I've not seen anybody So, Canadian caller said this
earlier and I've never seen this argument,
I do think this is this could get really interesting, right?
Wait, play it back again. What did you miss, Placido?
What did you miss? That Hutch for two or three weeks, you're
not the one actually suffering not having those benefits, right?
Well, I you lost me. I don't understand the question. Isn't that
So, Pisco's doing the the talking point, right? That these people
were picked by Schumer to go over. They're not getting they're
not in a midterm in 2026, so they don't have to they don't have
to worry about this being held against them in elections.
So, they can cross over and help Republicans. It's like if all
of them are like that, if every single Dem who's going to do
that, it seems very concerning. Privileged? You're not actually
internalizing the cost since you said, right? You would vote
okay. I'm a hypocrite. I'm sorry. Good point. I'm sorry. I'm
a hypocrite. I'm sorry. Can I Pisco, I want to call you out on
something. You you said something very dangerous, in my opinion.
You said He said I'm a hypocrite. I'm sorry.
That's that's like a slight conciliation or Yeah, it's a slight
it's a slight consensus. It's Oh my god, concession.
Concession. I swear to god, I'm not having a stroke. I promise
I'm not having a stroke. I don't know what that was. It's a temporary
temporary ischemic attack, okay? It's over. We're past it. Transitory
ischemic attack. It's over. >> to be the guys who vote
no. So, you're implying that Chuck Schumer is not sincere, Hakeem
Jeffries isn't sincere, that the entire Democratic Party you're
saying the entire Democratic Party is in on these this no vote.
No, I'm going to tell you exactly what I mean. I'm going to tell
you exactly what I mean. I'm going to tell you exactly I'll tell
you exactly what I mean. Tim Kaine said that there were more
senators. Ryan Geddes just agreed that there's definitely more
senators and among the caucus who didn't vote this way, even
though they agreed with that position. And Tim Kaine confirmed
that there were people behind the scenes saying, "We're glad
that what you're doing." And so, therefore, given the fact that
there are significantly more at least you know, and Tim Kaine
was suggesting more senators who agreed with this position and
only eight the exact amount of people. What what do you mean
they're bullshitting? Tim Kaine's lying then. Do you think Tim
Kaine is lying?
I have no idea. I have no idea what he's
My position is that Tim Kaine is
actually. There could have been people behind the scenes that
were almost there, that weren't there. They were but they were
still no's. Okay, I'm assuming Tim Kaine is telling the truth.
That like only two of the eight Schrödinger's squared right now.
IRI is Schrödinger's Tim Kaine's position.
are up for election
like next year. I I frankly, I think that there were definitely
more I think it they put up these ones that are all like half
of them are retiring and then like two more aren't going to be
up for election for another 6 years. And I >> Pisco's alleging
like a clandestine Democrat like scheme, right? It's more just
like obviously the ones genuine senators and genuine reps who
>> It's like a It's like a textbook example of a rotating
villain. I think that's obviously what's happening. I think the
situation is that there's a ton of political pressure on the
Democrats right now to prolong this fight from their base who
want them to continue fighting. And I'm I think a lot of senators
recognize the perils of that of that kind of situation and they
were happy to let people that are not in any real danger of an
immediate primary fall in the sort. I I think that's obviously
what's happening here. That's what I mean by handpicked. Yeah.
Okay. Well, I just Okay.
>> Dude, that's very funny that Hutch is like, "Yeah, I
think it's like basically exactly what Pisco's suggesting." And
now IRI is like, "Oh, fuck." Uh I guess that's everybody. I guess
everybody just agrees that this happened, including my other
Dem party shill. Uh-oh. I think the language is a little dangerous,
though, cuz it implies that there's some sort of like scheme
going
Cuz that I think that happens a lot where people like, "Well,
I'm going to wait and see who votes one way or another and then
I'll decide how to vote." Maybe they would have been the deciding
votes if these guys hadn't stepped forward, but these guys chose
to and and I think that's the end of it. But you're implying
that they like, "Okay, I'm going to vote yes, cuz I'm not up
for reelection till 2030, so I can still make I can still So
so I mean, that's true of Hutch then, cuz Hutch just described
to you that that's genuinely what he think happened, that people
um you know, I don't think it's What are you doing, man? What
the hell? Come on, Hutch. What are you doing,
Is literally a a scheme. They said they kept leadership informed.
Okay. Uh okay.
Interesting. I'd have to go see that. Is that Tim Kaine who said
that or who said that specifically? Also, guys, if you like the
content, go ahead, follow on every platform. Join the Discord,
Guys, if you want to make the stream go longer, you can throw
in a couple bucks. You can make it go longer. Let me see what
do we got here. We got
five We've got
seven subs for another hour on the stream right now. We're seven
subs away from another hour on the stream. I'll shill again in
about 10 minutes or at about 10 minutes, so it'll probably be
50 minutes. But if you want to sub, you can do so on Kick. If
you want to give money through one of the TTS mechanisms, I exclamation
point donate in the chat. There's the link, so you make the stream
go longer. Uh we'll keep going all night. And I need more hours,
so guys, get the donos in. I think I think that's obviously what's
happening here. I mean, like we we could exactly traded. We're
never going to know exactly what was traded, but it wouldn't
be the most surprising thing in the world if it was like Oh,
Chatty Nichols, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it.
Appreciate it. Hold on a second. Let me let me see what this
is. Schumer says he's voting no. Did you go outside leadership?
No, we kept leadership informed throughout. >> Senator
Chuck Schumer, your leader in the Senate, said I cannot support
a continuing resolution that fails to address health care. I
am voting no. Did you do this outside leadership and was there
a big push for you not to join the others and break the 60 threshold?
No, we kept leadership informed throughout and I think it's important
to
Bro, this why is this person from
Is this person brain damaged? What was the purpose
of saying this?
Now you This is like the all There's no upside to making this
statement except for you. Like right Like maybe you get uh slightly
less heat, but you've just undone everything about this. Shut
the [__] up. How did you not understand that doing
this meant you shut the [__] up? This is so embarrassing.
He's undone everything.
Oh, yeah, Chuck Schumer is trying not to fall on this grenade.
Do you What do you want to do? Oh, uh hold on. Let me get another
grenade under this guy so he falls on it. There we go. Who's
responsible for why we got into this shutdown. We are here because
we are concerned about the health care costs rising significantly
on millions of Americans.
I don't care about this person's opinion anymore. Total [__]
You know,
you know, vote take it take the hit on this one and you know,
we'll make sure you have extra input on this next thing coming
up. You know, I mean that's just how sometimes things work in
Congress. Um it's unfort- This is This is the person
where like Listen, I This guy's just lucky that there's nobody
else in here. There's no There's no like There's just Pisco who's
like been kind of riding on this this whole idea of like we have
boring people, they accept everything, they're weak, they're
losers, right? Cuz I guarantee you you had like uh >> Who
would Who would be a good example?
I don't know who a good example would be. Be a lot of people
calling for this guy's head right now, okay? It's just like I
Are you serious? Well, sometimes, you know, they might have given
us extra going forward. They're trying to They're trying to take
your country over. They're like They're like You You can't negotiate
with these people. They've proven This is like negotiating with
Russia. You can understand it in the Russia example. Why can't
you understand it in this example?
fortunate, but it's it's reality. And and and there's a lot of
non-overlap in the Democrats who voted uh in favor of the CR
in March. I noticed that. Brian Schatz is not there. Uh Kirsten
Gillibrand isn't there. Um I even think some of the
I think Ossoff No, I think Ossoff voted no both. Maybe. I'm not
sure. >> Voted no. Um yeah, so but like I I notice that
there's a lot of um If you were to pick
the most like optimal senators
to vote this way, it would be these people. It would be these
people. I'm saying that a whole Senate is in on some >> Why
not? Grand conspiracy. >> Warnock's He's not up. Warnock's
not up for re-election. He could have voted. I mean, I could
I could make the case for a bunch of these guys. Could have been
one of those votes. grand conspiracy orchestrated like by puppet
master Well,
the The point against conspiracy that I would see
is your moral You're less likely to weigh your election if it's
4 years Right? So there's a lot of people who know that they'd
look bad with coming up in the midterms and they probably are
voting no no matter what cuz they don't want to be the people
get painted as siding with Trump if they're going to get primary,
right?
So a lot of those people that would be top of mind for reasons
they wouldn't vote no. So you'd see none of those people go.
Even if it even possibly if it was like principally in their
in their interest or somehow in their interest to do so. Master
Chuck Schumer, but I'm certain that there were some overlapping,
you know, deals that were struck, you know, you're going to vote
for this and you know, we're going to you know, make sure that,
you know, the DNC is not, you know, maybe we're going to throw
a little bit more money to some super PACs, you know, in your
re-election campaign. I don't know. I just don't think that it's
I don't know. I I I am almost certain that it was predetermined
who who was going to be the no. Angus King Angus King said, "These
guys weren't going to budge and there was no moving them, the
Republicans. There was no moving them any further. Nothing else
would have helped. It was just going to make people suffer more."
So what do you say to him? >> with him? Wait, wait. So
why don't you agree with him, Myra? You said you don't >> saying
that's his reason and I I believe him. If he believes that, then
I I disagree, but I don't have all the facts in front of me.
I don't know. I'm not a senator from Maine and listening to my
constituents. I've no clue. But from my point of view, I think
they could have kept fighting. I'm just saying, "How do you respond
to his argument? You think he's just he just gave in or he's
he's >> Well, I think Angus King um is First of all, he
was against this in the first place. So Angus King voted no cuz
he's in So So when Angus King is like, "Wow, look at this amazing
vote we got in the Republican-controlled Senate." Like Angus
King doesn't give a [__] about this. He voted in
favor of opening the government on the Republican package in
the first vote. And so one is I think he and he's even like laughing
when he says, "I think it's a 50/50 that this eventually passes
the Democrat-written bill." He And he chuckles through it cuz
he can't actually like it's so preposterous that notion. So First
of all, Angus King's um you know, his own determinations I think
are questionable. But on the issue of whether the Republicans
would have ultimately bended, I'm not sure they would have. But
that's why you pick an issue that's so important and so critical
at the start that you are willing to um you know, have that be
your bottom line. Don't pick a bottom line if you're not willing
to stick to it. And I'll give you I'll even grant you this. If
it were the case that this were the optimal time to drop it and
this were the optimal time to sign on to this um you know, signaling
vote that means nothing, then why isn't the doling out of this
better PR strategized? Why isn't the case that we have more uniformity?
Why are we in a situation where you have the leading candidates
for for Maine Senate, right? Like Platner and Mills both saying
it is a [__] cave. Newsom, cave, cowardly, he says.
Pritzker, cowardly, cave. Why is it the case that our leading
candidates are all saying the most the worst possible things
on it? That doesn't seem like a good strategy even if this were
the optimal time to drop the fight. And if it's the case Sorry,
one last thing. If it's the case that Hut like as Hut said, Uh
Hut Hut is just like wildly uncomfortable all the And if it's
the case Sorry, one last thing. This is just all the time.
It's all the It's just all the time. >> One last thing.
If it's the case that Hut like as Hut said, um that it's the
fear of the base. I think that some of that is true. And the
fear of their own voters. What does that tell us about the disconnect
between the leadership and the voter? That just confirms it and
it confirms that they don't feel they can be honest to their
voter. I mean, that's Wait, I mean, real quick, let me just add
one thing and that's what is the signal to the Republicans? It's,
"Hey, if you give indications that you won't budge, no matter
how much you're hurting, you know, the SNAP recipients, the WIC
recipients, whatever, then Democrats will just eventually fold.
There's no point in ever like standing to any fight because all
you have to do is just say no over and over, no matter how much
it hurts your uh credibility, no matter how much it hurts your
polling, no matter how much it makes Donald Trump say he's going
to get rid of the filibuster, doesn't matter. Eventually Democrats
are going to fold. You can make people hurt for as long as you
want." And like what does that signal? It's like, "Okay, well,
we just negotiated with the the terrorist or whatever allegory
you want to use." Like why ever fight ever I think appeasement
and I think that's the best way. I think that's the best thing
ever. If they're never going to budge, they just will say no
and eventually enough senators will be like, "Well, they said
they weren't going to do anything, so we just decided to vote
no." >> And it's not your fault, Hut and Myra. I I know
you guys are looking at silver linings. I know and I think that
there's a lot of benefit to what's going on. I'm just It is so
frustrating as someone who was so like Hut is my boy. >> ecstatic
and happy about every of the Democratic Party doing well on Tuesday
to have this sort of put out in the middle of the night on the
weekend and to and to have this like just with no coordination
and seemingly
even if it isn't strategized at some level of leadership where
you have the whip, right? The Democratic whip is one of the leaders,
Dick Durbin from Illinois, it feels that way and they must have
known this would have So So that's where the frustration is coming
from and so I don't I'm not trying to make it personal, but you
know. I I understand. I'll just say when I saw that the deal
was made, I thought we just won the midterms because there'll
be no subsidies and people are going to get [__]
and they're going to be pissed and we just won the midterms.
I think we came out better for having done this. I just wish
we held out a little longer. That's literally my exact position,
by the way. Yeah, we all agree on that. Yeah. So So the to piggyback
off of what Myra is saying right now, like we're framing this,
I think we're we're only thinking about like the short term,
the the PR hit, like the the appearance of like fecklessness
or weakness. Like okay, that's fine. I guess that's a W for Donald
Trump for the next what? News cycle? What I like a week, two
weeks? How long are people going to be talking about this? But
what's the real-
At what point do you accept
>> that this is the Democratic Party's DNA? It's not feckless.
It's not like It's not appearance.
It's just in their DNA.
They're always going to back down. They're going to let Trump
do whatever he wants. Democrats barely better than Republicans
in terms [clears throat] of having a Barely. reality of the situation.
They just got creamed by margins that we haven't seen since 2008
in terms of the over overperformance. Like the numbers that came
out of last Tuesday are number You have to go back like almost
two decades to get that kind of overperformance.
And the reality is that these cuts are going to happen. And to
Ryan's point, I think they were always going to happen. I I think
I even expressed on this podcast a couple times. I don't know
how realistic it is to expect that we're going to get these full
tax credits back. Like I just don't know if the Republicans are
going to play ball. Maybe I I thought maybe we might get like
a like maybe half of the subsidy. I don't really know. Like a
quarter, just something. But this always kind of this feels like
this we were always headed to this outcome at some point or another.
And the reality is these premium spikes are going to impact tens
of millions of people in January. And the Republicans right now
are in charge of government. And anybody who thinks that Don-
Guess what? Those premium spikes, those would have hit those
people all the same. Guess what? They would have hit a lot harder
if a bunch of those people had to go under water for credit just
to
But those those are going to hit no matter what. Yes. Americans
are going to feel pain no matter what. Yes. Why why did you just
why did you let it up? Why did you let
I'm sorry. There's like you could have
You want to pass
You want to pack the court. You want to do it with like a 60-seat
majority in the Senate. This is the path. This you just got handed
the path and you just threw it down at the ground. The only chance
you ever had at this you never should have gotten a chance. The
Republicans should never have stood on this hill. But they did
cuz the only thing Trump can do is signal strength. That's all
he can do.
You had you had every opportunity to make this like the end of
the Republican
I I truly think it would be. Donald Trump is going to be able
to fool the public about who's to blame for these subsidies going
up? That is one of the most online takes I've ever heard in my
life. This is something that is just a truism just across the
board when it comes to politics. Anytime there's economic hardship
like a massive event where a lot of people experience economic
hardship, they always blame the party in power. But but Hutch,
he's going to give us the $2,000 tariff checks. He's the money
president now. Do you don't think that's going to sway them?
I ironically that is one of the most dangerous recent developments
in American politics. I mean this is one of the classic democracy
failure states. This you know, it people
people smear like welfare as like oh you know you know people
are just >> Yeah. Yeah yeah we're just going to it's going
to spiral into infinity. But this is not this is of a fundamentally
different kind than what we do with normal welfare or you know
direct benefits to people. Arbitrarily
looting the American people through tariffs imposed directly
by the president. And then using that money to send checks to
buy loyalty. I mean this is this is actually a
a remarkably
bad development for American democracy. >> going to say
you got to say the line, Ryan, which is this is incredibly dangerous
to democracy. Everyone Yeah yeah the Sinclair news line. No one's
talking about the real ending of ending the shutdown which is
we get to do Epstein discourse again when the house That's true.
You could have sold me on that though.
>> Like are we are we going to approve that last house
member? We're going to get the Epstein vote? I think Yeah she's
going to get sworn in. They have to. That's why they've been
holding the house out of session which is in itself an incredibly
unprecedented thing. The idea that
in theory the second or third most powerful person in the United
States government, the speaker of the house, um just chooses
to not call his own uh branch together to meet to have power
is um is crazy. I mean that that is that is that is crazy. And
um I wish that that registered as bad to more people. I understand
why it doesn't since you know we're not all so institutional
pilled, but um you know it is really bad. It's a great point.
Like the the notion of this Madisonian check power within the
federal government has completely collapsed and um except in
some of these key areas like I think probably tariffs even though
on tariffs the Republican Congress isn't willing to um like do
a negative vote on it, but they're not they're not going to actively
promote it. And similar thing I think on the filibuster, but
other than those like key few areas um it doesn't seem like um
there's or that the walls that existed between the executive
branch and the legislative branch are crumbling crumbling crumbling
and it's partisan that's sort of winning the day as opposed to
um you know these delineated branches of government. I think
it's I mentioned that. Oh the trouble with the verse Oh sorry.
You can go ahead. Oh yeah no I as we Has anybody Has [clears throat]
anybody watched this? Do we get any more like heated moments?
It feels like Hutch is still I feel like I can see the the sweat
sheening off of his bald forehead. I feel like he's going to
have more to say, but I'm not sure. >> this when I talked
to Newsom I said isn't the real issue of the shutdown shouldn't
it be hey we can't approve any spending bill until you promise
us that Trump is actually going to spend it the way the Congress
has has allocated it. Um and he said yeah that is the main issue,
but that's not resonant with voters. It's not as politically
salient, so we have to do it about health care which is still
important, but the main issue is well does Congress even matter
anymore? And it like the caving here you know kind of makes me
feel like I really do wish we would fight on that, but I understand
you can't message that to the American people and it's it's very
important that like yeah we we don't know if we really have three
branches of government anymore and we it's kind of eroding.
But go ahead, Ryan. Sorry. Oh no Hutch you were trying to get
in. No I mean I I wanted to piggyback off of like I want to go
back to what I was saying before which is that I disagree with
the vote last night. And one of the reasons why like we already
discussed was was like I do think this should have been stretched
out a little bit longer. I think my red line is just when people
stop losing that critical
those benefits. That's just I and I don't think like that is
like the obvious morally correct decision either. Like you it
might be correct to stretch that out because there could be some
bigger gain down the line and if somebody wanted to make that
argument I could be persuaded. It's just that's just like where
I would go with that. >> million people off of SNAP was
the only way to beat Trump. Bro um [__] [laughter]
It's an easy man. I don't know. What do you mean? That's an easy
yes, right? As always the calculation of He has to say no. He
has to say no to be consistent with what he said so far. He has
to say no. I wouldn't do that.
Cuz this is [clears throat] unironically the easiest way to beat
Trump. Like you you destroy Trump by doing this. It's like what's
going to do more harm. And so like I'd have to like really think
about that, but you know Yeah. I mean these are these are these
are >> over mass starvation? Yeah these are these are tough
>> Hutch. I don't know. I'd I'd sacrifice 41 million. I'd
sacrifice 50 million SNAP recipients. These are tough >> a
thousand children to stop fascism. The point is is like these
are not straightforward calculations. This is not a science.
And so
I think like
to kind of get back to I just don't understand. He's ends justify
the means in like all cases except for SNAP.
Like hey we need people who are pro-life and segregationists
in our party to to defeat Trump, okay? We need them. Wait Trump's
not that bad. Is Trump that bad? Trump's Trump's not that bad.
No I don't think we take 41 million people off of SNAP. No I
don't think so. >> I think the Democrats went wrong on
this it is insane to me that it's like okay fine if you if if
there was backroom deals and you picked these these senators
to be the ones to fall on the sword. Like I'm not morally offended
by that. That just seems like kind of standard politics to me
or whatever. I but the ones that they did pick did just about
the worst job you could possibly imagine in terms of making that
case. Like that Angus King line. I don't even think what he said
was technically >> working. It wasn't working. I don't
even think what he said was technically wrong, but it was so
politically stupid to go to have him be that person to go out
there and do that. But I think that does signal weakness. There
was another There were like two other people that did a press
conference today and I just think that they should there should
have been a more coherent plan in terms of how to navigate the
messaging. Or I I think maybe you could have even been straightforward
about like look we really want to raise the awareness of this
issue. It's really difficult to imagine Donald Trump you know
giving concessions here, but we want to inform as many people
as but like maybe you could have even been straightforward about
that to begin with. Like I don't know. Well better political
minds, but There's no guarantee this is going to pass in the
house by Oh you want to watch the Angus King moment? Okay. So
this guy this Angus King guy that they're talking about
he um
it looks like he was the one who
he was the one who announced this and he's been kind of smug
and didn't want this to go through the whole time. Or he's been
he's been with the Republicans on passing a CR the whole time.
It does not guarantee that it's going to happen. So how do you
explain though to your constituents why it was worth it to put
up this fight for so long when in the end you did not get your
key demand?
Because it wasn't working.
How long would it take
to not get a response
to say it isn't working. In other words, it's been 6 weeks.
There's been no the Republicans made it clear they weren't going
to discuss the health care issue the Affordable Care Act tax
credits
until until the shutdown was over. The funny thing is
Oh Matt, could you imagine being like a Republican senator and
like the group chats you're in? Just like the relief. Like you
don't have to deal with the fact that Trump's like destroying
the country. Like he's he's actually just going to totally like
Every essentially every family in the US will be affected by
this. Right? And you're going to have to deal with that. That
you're the party in power. You have all three chambers or sorry
all three um You don't have all three chambers. You have both
chambers of Congress. You have the executive entirely, right?
You Actually they do have all three branches as well. You have
control of everything. How are you not going to get blamed? How
the [__] do you get out of getting
And then yes it's like dude I it makes no sense that they capitulated,
but they did. Thank God. Thank God we don't have to own this.
Thank Christ. And the way they capitulated out of nowhere for
actually makes it look like we were in the right the whole time.
These stupid
>> My God. We tried to keep working that for 6 weeks. It
didn't happen. The vote that we have is not a guarantee for sure.
It's more of a guarantee Here's the way I would put it. As As
I assessed it, there was zero chance of dealing with the ACA
issue as long as the shutdown continued.
I don't know, 50/50?
But if there's Why is it 50/50?
If you had any indication that you were going to have people
break ranks to vote with you, why would you have capitulated
Do you know how it looks if they vote with you now? They literally
You've guaranteed they
Then it Then it's a Republican shutdown and they wasted everybody's
time cuz they offered a a vote and they were going to go with
you anyway. There's a lot better chance now than there was this
morning. A vote on the extending the the tax credits it does
not guarantee that it's going Ay ay ay ay ay ay ay ay.
Okay. By the way, they they you know, like they could run into
some trouble. 50/50. Guys, there's a 50/50 chance that with our
minority in the Senate, they'll just vote with us. There's a
50/50 chance. Either it happens or it doesn't happen. It's 50/50,
guys. He's doing He's literally doing the Anchorman moment. Guys,
it's 50/50. It either happens or it doesn't. over there. I don't
think so. But But So Schumer should step down, then, right? They
can only lose two votes on >> before we before we light
a new fire.
>> Uh before that out of the fire a chatter was talking
about it and maybe you guys know more about this that Mike Johnson
was considering not even taking the vote. I mean, did you see
something about that? Cuz I hadn't >> ACA? On the ACA stuff,
yeah.
Yeah, because and everyone knows it. That's why this like It's
a It's a nothing. It's saying we're getting nothing. You know,
it it's not a deal at all. It's Well, hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. I I want I want IRI's Facebook for this. Hold on. That 50/50
might be so might not be so Guys, hold on. I Oh, hold on. Let's
not count out the ACA subsidy extension here. So, the Democrats
have been given a guarantee of a vote by the second week of December.
That might get some momentum going. There are Republicans that
want to see these ACA subsidies extended and I I don't think
it's an impossible thing for that to pass and then the Republicans
in the Senate have so much pressure on our Republicans in the
House feel pressured to do something. I mean, Mike Johnson said
we got to do something about these ACA subsidies, but we got
to negotiate after the government's open. So, I mean, people
are just acting like it's the dead. Man.
Hey, IRI.
IRI seems like um like a guy who's followed politics for a while,
like a guy who knows how the Republican Party acts. Didn't the
Didn't the Republicans soy the [__] out about you
guys nuking the filibuster
to get a senator through? And then didn't they do that same thing?
Isn't that like the story from back then?
Like the the Dems didn't get rid of the filibuster to to No,
no, no. They didn't get rid of the filibuster to elect a Supreme
Court justice, right? To to pass one, to confirm one? And then
didn't the didn't the Republicans do the same
Didn't they like literally nuke the filibuster to get a Supreme
Court justice through? Or am I crazy? I thought that was how
it went. I wouldn't I wouldn't be so sure. I think that's delusional.
I don't know. I think it's delusional. >> delusional I
mean, I'm talking about people on policy grounds who cut Medicaid
by like $800 billion
to to pay for their tax cuts. These are people who ran on destroying
the ACA. And now out of the head of Zeus you're going to fund
it more? I don't think so. >> Why did Mike Johnson and
Trump say, "Yeah, we got to do something about that then?" Cuz
they're liars. They're liars. senators There's a couple senators
who will something about that then? Cuz they're liars. They're
liars. senators There's a couple senators who will vote for it.
There's a couple
Did IRI just look like bewildered at the idea that Mike Johnson
and Trump are liars? Pisco says they're liars and he's like,
"Well, whatever, bro." He like actually has a look of like confusion
and like he he disbelief. Oh, okay, I guess you're just going
to say they're liars then.
He watched C-SPAN ALL THE TIME. You can perfectly elucidate why
they're liars any other moment of the day.
They're liars. senators There's a couple senators who will vote
for it. There's a
This is why, okay? Somebody Somebody in this chat said earlier
today, I don't know if you guys were all here, okay? Somebody
in the chat, I'm not going to out them, but they were talking
about how they really appreciate IRI's thinking process. And
I I kind of tore into them cuz I'm like there is no thinking
There's no thought process. He will just defend Democrats no
matter what all the time. It's not interesting. It's not cool.
It's not anything. There is no thought process there, right?
Why the [__] would you say that? That was the stupidest
[__] thing you could say. You would say, "Oh, I appreciate
his way of like backwards rationalizing anything the Democrats
do." You said something like that. Hold on between the stars.
Let me I wasn't outing you, but you said it. I like IRI and his
Dem Party stances. They're honestly refreshing the online spaces,
especially the lefty spaces, even if I disagree with them. So,
that's saying you appreciate his stances. Something about them.
They're refreshing.
What about them is refreshing? That Okay, what about this stance
is refreshing? Cuz this is like IRI This is how I see him like
This is what me off about him every single time I see him. Is
he'll He's like perfectly capable of understanding things, but
he'll just become selectively re out of nowhere. Like totally
selectively re No explanation. To the point that he'll act like
he can't believe that Pisco just called Mike Johnson and Trump
liars. Like he's
Whatever you say, Pisco. I don't know about that, man. couple
Republican senators who will vote for it. But it will not be
enough. Yeah, and if they were serious about voting for it at
all, why wouldn't they say, "Okay, cool. Let's vote for an extension
right now and end the shutdown." >> Let's see. Like like
Like I said, the a big They were serious about voting on What?
Like you know they're not serious about voting on it because
what I think this is what Soy Pillow was just trying to say,
right? Not vote on it right now. Literally, why wouldn't they
just grant it and end the shutdown? If they were serious about
voting on it and they thought he could have any votes there to
possibly pass this, why wouldn't they just go months ago, "Oh,
yeah, we'll give you that and we'll end the shutdown." What was
the purpose of totally tanking their numbers up until
big chunk of people took advantage of those subsidies in the
last few years are in red states and they're conservatives. I
mean, who the [__] audience? Who
Where are a bunch of the people who are on food stamps
that aren't going to have their governors their state governors
pay for it. I don't need to say state governors.
superfluous. Okay, so their governors. It's all red states, bro.
It's all red states. Who Who's is that? That chatter mark there?
What the [__] Which chatter? I don't know. Yeah,
you're going to have to be a little more specific on your >> be
my free speech chat. Is it cosmic Dude, there's no way he's getting
one guy'd right now. Hold on. Hold on. >> advantage of
those subsidies in the last few years are in red states and they're
conservatives. I mean, can we see? Who the [__] audience?
Who Who Who's is that? That chatter mark Oh, I saw a Hutch comment
there for a second. Hold on. There was a Hutch comment went by
pretty fast.
When Hutch says the lulu, you know it's >> chatter mark
there. What the [__] Which chatter? I don't know.
Yeah, you're going to have to be a little more It might be my
free speech chat. Is it cosmic cosmic something? Who the [__]
Yeah, Cosmic Milarepa. I've never been so triggered in my entire
life. Cosmic I don't know where is it.
The House will not bring it up.
Cosmic Milarepa. I don't see him. I don't see him. Get him up
there. Oh, boy, he's in mine. He's in mine. Leave him alone.
No. No, we we work here for Oh, do they add all of their chats
to this? Is this like everybody's chat coming in to simultaneously?
Oh, that's interesting.
Obamacare last night. There's a lot of
Like I genuinely feel like a majority of people that are screaming
about this online don't actually know what happened last night.
That's my sense of things. Because that's not That is not what
I think that that is like so You want to talk about out of touch.
I I I don't think that that's like of the people who are commenting
on it, you don't think that they they know enough to be critical
on what's going on? I've just see a lot takes like, you know,
I saw so many takes of people saying Dem Hutch, for a guy who
doesn't like Hasan, Hutch employs a lot of Hasan's tactics,
He's like He's like totally soying at Pisco that he's too out
of touch to like really argue that SNAP benefits should be suspended
for the sake of having this fight on the shutdown. And then right
in the next swoop he's like, "You're too dumb to talk about this.
Why the [__] are you in my chat? You're just a trans
Pisco chatter."
>> voted to take That is related to Hasan. He's He's like
Right? Hasan soys about trans issues and he's like, "You're just
a trans person."
Hutch is soying about poor and dumb
"You're too stupid and uninformed to talk about this." >> away
your health care last night and that's not what happened. That
is not what happened. That Okay. I think it is really important
that we don't lose the impetus of whose fault this all is. Yeah,
I mean, it is the Republicans fundamentally who are in charge
of all three branches of government. Sure don't look like that
now. Sure looks like a couple of Democrats broke ranks, went
over and said, "I can't let this I can't let my party do this
anymore. I'm compelled by by my morals to stop this, to end my
party's shutdown." That's what it looks like now. That's the
easiest line to sell people in the world and if you don't understand
that, you are a
And if they I'm
It's their fault, you know? And this is why I don't feel so bad
about saying like, you know, we should have you know, kept it
kept it going for as long as they I think my line to reopen the
government I think it would have been a guaranteed vote in both
houses. I think
I don't think that that was unreach able. I think that that was
reachable. Um and I think that the fact that we couldn't get
to that was Wait, they didn't even offer a vote in the House?
They're just like, "We'll vote on it in the Senate." No way,
right? No way. That can't be possible.
It's probably cuz [laughter] you do have more runway here. Um
you know, even if you accept that SNAP funding were to run out
in 2 months or something. There's more runway and so at least
on the snap stuff so that's your your bottom line is when contingency
funds run out for snap
I think that you have more runway here. But but what is the point?
Given Mike Johnson left the meeting and saying I promised nothing
to anybody in response. Okay.
Only Senate vote and they don't even have enough votes for that.
The colossal failure of Schumer to keep his caucus in line for
his position. He should re I think it would be really cool just
for the meltdown Pisco would have if John Fetterman came out
and voted against those tax credits in the Not that it would
matter or would be required. It would just be one vote into the
majority that would clearly deny them already. But it would be
really funny if if John Fetterman just came out and just decided
to style on Pisco. For some reason he knows who Pisco is and
he's just like, "Hey, you to this guy from New York City who
does politics content. You specifically talk about primary me,
bitch." Resign, shouldn't
But but here's the thing, Pisco, it doesn't like the snap cards
don't get loaded the day after the government opens. This takes
time. It could take weeks to get the snap program back
Sure, but you don't think we had a month like we have what? Like
5 to 6 billion dollars in contingency funds. >> That's
2 weeks. They said that's 2 weeks. Like like Hutchison >> so
then you grant the 2 months of runway. You grant that there's
2 more weeks of runway. That's already ran out in November. So
that 4.5 billion was for the first 2 weeks of November, you know,
or 2 weeks whenever it starts. >> But then I don't actually
understand why you're against the vote, IRI. I mean like I I
hear you say that you're against it, but then you're like they
had to do it now or snap was going to run out. And so so I'm
I'm not understanding what's the basis for you saying that you're
against it. I'm putting I'm just I I am quite dubious that it
would take that long to like there is probably some delay of
like we have to decide where the funds
But to me like snap is probably the most important thing the
government does at large scale that's like being affected,
Like they can't not pay out social security, I don't think. I
think that gets paid out no matter what. They cannot pay out
Medicaid. Snap would be like a oh, what's the word? It's like
uh like snap is one of the it's like choice base. You you decide
whether or not to fund it. There are things things
like entitlements you can't not fund. I think that's all protected
still, right? And it's still getting paid out. But like this
stuff it's got to be the highest one of the
priority discretionary spends, yes. Discretionary spends that
exists to get it back going again.
Just steelmanning their argument, I still think the fight was
worth it for those ACA subsidies because it's going to affect
all of our insurance premiums across America even if we're not
on through the getting insurance through the ACA. But I I'm I'm
trying to understand where those eight senators are coming from
instead of just saying that they folded like cheap suits and
they're weak and they're pathetic. >> Oh, snap is a part
of that. Oh, I didn't know that. I'm trying to actually understand
where they're coming from. Like I don't think Tim Kaine is just
some scrub. Like this guy is a serious player in the Senate.
And if he he represents the state of Virginia, you know, a state
with a lot of federal workers. And I think like we're people
are just discounting their reasoning for why they did because
maybe they gave a bad speech or something. But I I think these
guys had genuine concerns. >> Schumer wasn't convinced
if you take his official position. So if Schumer wasn't convinced,
he he should resign, shouldn't he? He wasn't able to keep his
caucus in line as leader of the Schumer Schumer should resign
because he's lost the confidence of the party. That's why he
should resign. It's good for Yeah. It's It's good for the party.
Like I feel like if he resigned literally in internally the numbers
would go up like 20 points immediately. I agree. Because because
it would look like Yeah, go ahead, Ron. Oh, no, I agree with
that take fully. No, sorry. My bad. I'm jumping in. Oh, go ahead.
Jump right in. Biden stepping down moment where everyone's like,
"Holy [__] Somebody new." You remember that was the
best week of our lives that last year and I think we can we can
recreate that.
That's the best week of our lives. IRI, this is the worst worst
week of his entire life. Uh worst week of his entire life. I
argued with IRI on a stream once that I think in like December
like the December of 2023.
No. No, December 2022. Maybe January
Joe Biden's too old. Get him the [__] out of the
race. He's clearly too old. He can't do it. He is cooked. He's
totally cooked. You got to run somebody else. There is no way
you can run this guy. He's too old.
and IRI argued back.
He was not a fan, okay? So he felt, "This is the best week of
my life."
Leaving him. I mean that's that's it. I mean I don't really think
that this is any different from any I mean frankly if anything
him voting no on this I feel like would be, you know, like good,
right? I mean like, you know, that's like more of what we want
to see from leadership if if you're of the mind that we want
a leadership with some more fight in them. But I think he needs
to go because
exactly what Hutch said. He's lost the confidence of the So IRI,
what's what's your hold up? Why why are you What would it take
for you to say Schumer needs to step down? Him coming out and
saying that he wants to step down? Like what what what is the
thing that will make you The thing that gives me pause is who's
going to replace him? Chris Murphy. There's so many people in
the I think Chris Murphy's This was
Speaking of the Biden thing IRI just somehow made the same defense.
What? I just don't know who's going to replace him. How about
anybody? He's an old who everybody hates. That wasn't even true
for Biden. That wasn't even true for him. By Everybody liked
Biden. As much as he was an old people liked him. Now it's Now
it's even worse cuz everybody hates Chuck Schumer. He's not going
to replace him. Come on. >> He can, he should, he would
do better. And so would Van Hollen. You don't think he's not
in a high leadership position though. Like I don't give a [__]
about seniority and you shouldn't either. Because no, but there's
a reason why these people are in leadership positions because
they have the confidence of the caucus and they know what they're
doing in the leadership position. So if you think Chuck Schumer's
bad, wait till you see the next guy. They're probably a million
times worse. Guy, you don't you don't Oh, go ahead, Ron. dismiss
that because the Republicans started down this train in the '90s
actually. Whenever they started throwing out their leadership
because they wanted more aggressive opposition. And they basically
haven't stopped for 30 years. Like every once in a while they
will get a new group of people who comes in and demands, you
know, more aggressive opposition. They'll throw out an old leader.
You know, it started with like Newt Gingrich and then he himself
got thrown out and then, you know, we just kind of kept going
on this It's Boner neck here. So I definitely don't want Democrats
to spiral down that way. So it's not an unreasonable concern
just to IRI's point. Dude. I don't know nothing about John Boner,
but I feel like when I see his face he like somehow seems like
one of the most recognizable people in the world to me. I don't
know why. He has like the perfect villain face. He just looks
like an actual Not this one. That looks like he's crying. What
the
That looks like he's about to cry. What He looks like a
Bayner? You. I'm going to say Boner cuz that's that's how I've
always said it, okay? He just looks like a villain to me somehow.
I don't know.
I I was like too young to really follow politics or care about
it at all like American politics. He just looks like a villain
all the time.
Bayner? You. Boner. John Boner.
I do think that Schumer in this case does need to step down though.
I think it's that bad. He is causing just he like he is, you
know, whatever you think about his leadership, you know, that's
not really a factor in the calculation whatsoever. But him being
in that role is divisive right now. It is dividing the party.
There's a lot of animosity. To a lesser extent there's animosity
to Jeffries, but it seems like the bulk of the animosity is being
directed at Schumer. I think he just represents
what in many people's minds are the, you know, the gerontocracy.
He represents a kind of old guard that a lot of Democratic voters
want to get rid of after being burned by Biden. Frankly, they
were burned by Biden. And I I think it's just the right thing
to do because it's a selfless act just the same as like I didn't
have personally I didn't have any doubts that Biden could have
served another term and been a good president and done fine.
I didn't have the same like when he had the bad night on the
debate on the debate stage I wasn't thinking like, "Oh my god,
he can't be president." I was thinking, "Oh my god, he might
have just lost the confidence of the entire party." And I think
we're just well beyond that point with Schumer. And I think that
he needs to like he should do the right thing and be selfless
in this moment. IRI, you wanted to jump in here. What were you
saying? Well, I was going to say how many Americans how many
Democrats even know who Schumer is? I feel like it's a much smaller
number than you think. Like it's, you know, most people have
no clue what who these people are. They don't know who Hakeem
Jeffries is. Nothing. So When you say that he's dividing our
party I feel like he's dividing a segment of the internet. No,
look at his look at his approval ratings. He's got he's got the
worst approval He's got like 23% approval ratings. I mean it's
it's really I don't know. It doesn't seem like there's going
to be anything else good here. I'm watching. I'm like
It does feel like there's probably other stuff we get to tonight.
Let me see here. Where are we at for the stream? Guys, we are
six subs. Six subs from another hour on the stream. Guys want
to load it up? Throw up We got We got six We're six away or $30,
all right? Either one. If we don't get through here, I'll probably
I could probably do some Patreon content tonight. I'm I'm feeling
the Patreon content, all right? Let me take a look. Let me take
a look. It's uh Wait, where's my where's my chat? And I can't
pull up this ice clip. Gummy verse thinks this is a pallet cleanser.
LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
>> IS THAT
WOW. WHO CARES? Somebody pooped.
Somebody Guys, somebody But thank you
for the link.
for the link. Jesus.
Marvin dude, thanks for the 500 kicks. That is We're now down
to five subs. Five subs from another hour on the stream. Very
cool. >> I'd love to see how many people on those polls
say, "Who?" But you don't actually think Like Chuck Schumer You
don't know what Oh my god dude, but what would it take? What
would it take? What would it What would it have to be 2% approval?
Let me say Let me just say Hold on. Hold on. You don't actually
think that he's the only one that could be Senate leader, right?
Like that's that's very Trumpy. That's very >> not. There's
plenty of people There's plenty of people that could step up
and fill his shoes and be a good leader. >> If If he dies,
we just have to dissolve the Democratic Party.
Last last thing to throw on the fire, guys, do you think he voted
for Mondaire Jones? He wouldn't tell us.
No, he voted FOR CUOMO.
>> COME ON. THIS IS SO OBVIOUS.
YOU GUYS LISTEN, I respect Schumer for what they were able to
accomplish under different Democratic presidents. I respect Pelosi.
And she's retiring for their accomplishments under Biden. I I'm
not doing this from an ideological perspective. He's too old.
He's too out of touch. He can't do the job anymore. Whatever
he did All right. I'm good on this. That was pretty funny to
watch for a little bit. Hutch decided to step to Pisco. Uh Pisco
was not having it. Hutch totally But Pisco still kept yelling
at